a leader in my community allow myself
along with other minorities to wear
culturally significant items during
their graduation ceremony this not only
commemorates their hard work but allows
them to be representatives of their
culture to their culture in closing i
would like to leave you with this quote
be the change you wish to see if you
want if you want this to if you want
this change so badly you will please
kindly consider this policy change thank
you mr robinson
[Applause]
go ahead for the record my name is
ashley garcia
good evening my name is ashley garcia
valladares and i am currently a senior
in rancho high school and i am the
president of speech and debate we're at
a time where i'm about to graduate and
i've accomplished many things throughout
the school year and i'm proud of how far
i've progressed i want to not only show
what i've accomplished through my hard
earned courts medals and high school
diploma but i also want to celebrate my
identity the motion i want to bring into
discussion today concerns graduating
students and the dress code
quote unquote no jewels or decorations
on caps or gowns no lays stoles cords or
medals other than those issued by
respective ccsd high school i find this
rule to violate upon my rights as a
student and a citizen in the united
states known as declared in a supreme
court case known as tinker v des moines
students were able to express their form
of symbolic speech as long as it does
not cause an undue disruption being able
to wear a mexican guatemalan flag along
with my hard-earned medals
chords and high school diploma is how i
express my symbolic speech i want to
have the ability to celebrate the fact
that as a young hispanic and first
generation woman that i was able to
graduate during a pandemic that's a huge
accomplishment not everyone in this room
can say that they endured they endured a
year in high school online
now and they also enjoyed other chaos
around that whole year that's again a
huge accomplishment and i want to
display that we can easily include
diversity and allow students to
represent their individuality and not at
the expense of maintaining decorum i
propose that the cultural heritage and
identity based graduation items be
approved upon to give students like me
and those who signed our petition the
opportunity to celebrate our identities
to honor to honor our families and our
communities
i want to show that any student is
capable of achieving their diplomas
regardless of ethnicity religion gender
sexual orientation or income status
thank you
thank you miss garcia valdez
welcome
hi uh for the record my name is jacob
drum
okay
uh so
when do i begin okay
my name is jacob drum and i am a senior
at green valley high school oh one thing
i sorry
my name is jacob drummond i'm a senior
at green valley high school one thing i
believe in is rationality and another
thing i believe in is education and i
believe that we should create incentive
structures so that a rational student
would want to perceive a good education
now of course not all students are
rational and really no student is but
at the very least our incentive
structures should incentivize students
to go to class and a rational student
should want to go to class from the
incentive structure
however this is in contradiction with
the green valley tardy policy and with a
lot of tardy policies that exist right
now
if you go to school and i'm five minutes
late
what am i going to do am i going to go
to class or am i going to sit in my car
well i'm going to tell you right now i'm
going to sit in my car and get that
absence excused and i'll tell you why
because on the first
first absence and the second sorry in
the first and second tardy you get a
detention and a parent notification
now if you are a rational student and
you are five minutes late to class
because perhaps something happened on
the way to school perhaps you know
something happened at home
what are you going to do are you going
to go to class or are you going to sit
in your car
you're going to sit in your car and
throughout the many conversations i've
had with fellow students they all agree
on this i've gotten text messages from
my friends many times saying hey i'm not
in class or i would ask them why aren't
you in class and they would say
well do i want a detention or would i
rather just get my absence excused for
literally no penalty
for this reason i believe it is
imperative that we change the tardy
policy structures that we incentivize
students to go to class i'd also like to
note it might be tempting to say why
don't we punish them harder for being
absent i don't think punishment is the
right solution here i think we should
make students want to go to class and
overall i just believe that you know we
should create a structure in which a
rational human being would want to
pursue an education rather than not go
to class as it is right now so that's it
and thank you very much
thank you mr drum please thank you for
completing your yellow form mr drum
jacob
if you could please uh give us your
yellow form if it's completed
thank you so much
are there any other students in the
audience who would like to
address public comment on agenda items
nope at this time i'd like to
congratulate the seniors who are in the
room thank you for your hard work
we are very proud of you
moving on um
the first person in public comment is
jenna robertson after jenna we've got
vicki croydell and autumn tampa
welcome
thank you my name is jenna robertson i'm
a mom of five ccsd students and i had
planned to come here tonight to talk
about how complicated the new coaster
process is how difficult it is to
navigate especially online and how
frustrating to have no appeals process
our family bought a new home after the
cosa deadline and while no kid likes
change or wants to leave their friends
one of my children was in significant
distress over changing schools
she had gotten some incorrect
information from a teacher about simply
applying for his own variants and when i
told her the process was different this
year and her school didn't have openings
and there was nothing i could do she was
convinced i just wasn't advocating for
her enough
um she was angry and then she was
distraught and based on the information
on the ccsd website
[Music]
excuse me ladies and gentlemen please do
not engage with the audience excuse ms
robinson we will pause your time
thank you at this time i'd like miss
robertson to get
jenna hi jenna thank you so much for
your patience
you're welcome to continue okay
um
my daughter was angry and then she was
distraught about changing schools and
based on the information on the ccsd
website i felt hopeless after my first
no i wrote my trustee to express my
frustration and ask if there truly was
nothing to be done
i received an email from the cosa
assistant again telling me no sorry so
just when i was planning to come here
and say student mental health has to be
more than a buzzword at a press
conference for this district i learned
that my trustee took a student's request
and her mental health seriously she got
my email to the superintendent and to
joe caruso who got my plea to the right
department
then i got a third correspondence from
the cosa department where we learned we
did in fact qualify for an
administrative something something and
my daughter would get to stay at her
current school you have never seen a
more relieved kid or a more relieved mom
trustee guzman
thank you sincerely for hearing my kid
thank you for taking her mental health
seriously it was really an issue in our
home it is no longer an issue in our
home thank you
um superintendent jara thank you for
your staff that communicated so clearly
with me during this whole process online
not clear at all once i got somebody on
the phone fantastic thank you
um i especially want to thank joe caruso
and i want to thank gm moore with the
cosa department who spent time on the
phone with me yesterday thinking that i
was still upset i was not i'm almost
done please i was interrupted please
um i want to thank you
i want to thank you all
on behalf of my daughter
who knows that her mom tried her best
and who knows that i reached out to you
on this board and she knows that you
tried your best for her too it worked
out for us
thank you
that's all thank you thank you jenna
that's robertson
miss croydell
thank you for finding your way out of
our boardroom
appreciate it
go ahead ms crowdell
good evening
my name is vicki craidel i'm ccsd
teacher and president of nea of southern
nevada
school board meetings are business
meetings we're here because we want our
district to work we want the kids to
feel safe and successful
i also encourage educators to tell you
they're bored when something isn't right
but here and all over the u.s school
boards are under attack
the attacks are done by groups of parent
advocates with similar sounding names
the focus changes from masks to crt
then it pivots to sex education etc
although these people say they're trying
to protect their kids from
indoctrination their agenda is really to
cause division and damage public school
districts
these people have taken what were quiet
business meetings most of the time
and changed them into occasional
screaming matches
educators are being called names accused
of all sorts of things from suffocating
kids with masks to being groomers
we're being slandered here and libeled
on social media
but make no mistake in all these
meetings the goal is to disrupt school
business and to silence educators
these actions are strategic well-funded
and coordinated just listen to board
meetings from tennessee to california
and you'll hear the same themes over and
over
they're meant to
i learned a lot about what's going on
from nea
and president becky pringle says at a
time when our students need us most and
when parents and educators have been
working together in partnership to do
everything we can to support
our students it is unconscionable that
this orchestrated disinformation
campaign has resulted in educators and
school board members being targeted
threatened and harassed
you see all of this is distracting us
from truly helping our students
they need our undivided attention as we
recover from this pandemic we need to
prioritize school safety and teacher
retention urgently
we must stand up against these attacks
on our public schools and see it for
what it is a distraction for what's
really important thank you ms crodell
miss tampa autumn tampa
welcome
i'm still being careful
um
hey
wait for lisa get ready
autumn tampa speaking as an individual
first year i would like to congratulate
and applaud the students who were here
and spoke tonight and all the graduating
class of 2022.
um i have really been torn about all
that i have been seeing over the past
several years in this country and the
impact that dissenting opinions and
social discontent are having on the
education of our children
i believe that a school should teach
academics with wrap-around services for
students in need
teachers and education support
professionals should not have to be
parents or psychiatrists or social
workers yet oftentimes we have had to be
because children's needs are not being
met
these are societal issues that our state
government needs to provide for
all year most ccsd employees have had
added workloads we have had coveted
safety protocols to implement and follow
we have had to be nurses doctors and
counselors we have had challenges with
student behavior and student loss
over the past year i have had some the
some of the same realizations that i've
had time and time again
one of the most damaging and critical
issues being that there still is the
downton abbey effect in ccsd
that is a perspective by administrators
not all but some that education support
professionals and often teachers are
servants not employees with feelings and
hopes and dreams and lives of their own
we are supposed to do as we are told
without question
and to go along with any and everything
we are told even if these requests are
unreasonable
we are not respected we are ignored
and constantly being asked to do more
and still more without fair compensation
this is probably one of the most
important reasons why ccsd employees are
leaving in droves and that there are
over 2 000 employee vacancies at ccsd
right now
there is much that needs to be done
actions speak louder than words thank
you
thank you miss tampa ladies and
gentlemen i'm just going to ask you to
please refrain from clapping in the
audience i really appreciate this so we
can get through more individuals mr jose
rivera is next along with kathia sotelo
and i just want to point out that we are
we'll be at 5 26 by the time that
they're done and i'd like to ask my
colleagues whether they would like an
extra 10 minutes of public comment okay
perfect thank you welcome good afternoon
my name is jose rivera i am a former
student of the ccsd school district
a current environmental justice
organizer for make the road nevada i am
speaking today to urge the trustees to
provide water bottle refilling stations
for all schools in the district
we obviously live in a desert where
children are exposed to extreme heat
temperatures during the summer causing
dehydration and irritation which can
then lead to health concerns
water bottle filling stations can
encourage children to hydrate not only
this but these stations can filter out
aesthetic chlorine taste odor and lead
from the water our children drink at
school
i am aware that schools are already
equipped with drinking fountains but
this is unsanitary especially in a
pandemic it would be more sanitary to
provide these water bottle filling
stations as the fountain's bubbler head
would not be touched by a child's mouth
and instead water will pour straight
into a student's reusable water bottle
water bottle filling stations and
schools will not only ensure a positive
outcome in a student's health but also
lead us to more eco-friendly solutions
within our district thank you thank you
so much jose mr rivera kathia
is cathy here
how about andy romero
audrey
perla peralta
jacob parker
abraham lugo
welcome abraham
go ahead
hello everyone um abraham lugo last name
l ugo for the record
good evening thank you for being here
today and for your active listening to
our comments i'm here as a former
student of ccsd a now unlv alumni and
the economic justice organizer for make
the road nevada
in my time with make the road my
responsibility has been to meet the
community where they're at and listen
i've interacted with countless of
working parents struggling in their
financial stability at a time where
we're barely coming out of pandemic
strikingly high inflation affects the
cost of everyday living and wages that
are unreflective for the needs of
survival of a working individual
let alone any children they may need to
provide for
statistically communities of color
disproportionately affected at the
forefront of such struggles their
children being no exception to such a
reality
as a personal testament to someone who
has
faced heavy tolls as a result of being a
witness to my family's financial
stresses i cannot emphasize enough the
pivotal nature of ensuring that mental
health professionals are placed within
our schools
where ccsd may not be able to fix every
child's home life they can ensure that
teachers are not the ones picking up the
pieces in every one of their dozens of
student lives but that trained
professionals are readily available to
guide support and possibly change the
course of a student's life for the
better at such troubling times
as we're all well aware our state is one
of the last in the nation for education
so changes must be made fiscal changes
that prioritize our students their
experience at school and creating a safe
space to alleviate their experience at
home as well
let us work together rather than on
separate playing fields to create an
equitable funding formula that sets the
foundation for this crucial change i
offer myself the voice of every student
and every youth leader that has come out
today to help you on this task our youth
deserve to thrive not just survive
because we all do thank you
thank you so much mr lugo thank you
ladies and gentlemen for refraining from
clapping kendra evans diana baptista
batista
welcome
hello my name is kendra evans i'm
i'm going to read you an assignment
given to my
ms kendra
is everything okay yeah
okay go
ahead yeah
it's kendra she's going to read it for
me
yes uh that's fine
nope forgive me that's not fine
sorry
so yes
okay okay
thank you i'm going to read you an
assignment given to my
15 year old daughter at a local high
school
this will be horrifying for me to read
to you but that will give you
perspective on
how she must have felt when her teacher
required her to memorize this
and to act it out in front of her entire
class
i don't love you it's not you it's just
i don't like your dick or any dick in
that case i cheated joe
i'm sorry
excuse me i i don't thank you so much
for your thank you for your uh comment
forgive me i'm we're not using profanity
are you
that's relevant
okay the teacher this required my
daughter to read memorize this and read
this pornographic material
excuse me please don't engage with the
audience okay
so please continue your public comment
your your time is you've got one at one
minute and 19 seconds
i ask you simply this is a public
meeting i asked for decorum um and i'm
asking
dr jarrah thank you so much dr jara
if you don't want me to read it to you
what was that like for my 15 year old
daughter to have to memorize
pornographic material
and
um
and memorize it and
madam president members of the board
staffs on this um we can have the regent
superintendent speak to her thank you so
much dr jarrah it seems like you may
have some concerns and while we're not
allowed to engage back and forth on the
dialogue we would absolutely like to
make sure that your concerns are
addressed
this material just finished what i was
going to say please
my daughter was forced to engage in the
portrayal of this
blank activity by her teacher we have
pornography laws regarding minors in
this state and many of those were
violated because of this assignment i
don't have time to to name all of the
laws that were broken that day but one
example nrs 200 710 it states it is a
crime when a person knowingly uses
encourages entices or permits a minor to
be the subject of a sexual portrayal in
a performance
in one of my meetings with school
administration they blame my daughter
for not saying no to the assignment
they blamed my daughter who is the
victim
teachers are in a position of power
educators must understand the laws about
sexual abuse and that is where i am
hoping you will help
if i had not reached out to a local
parent advocacy group howard parent for
help i may never have gotten a meeting
with the regional superintendent and
truly phil this incident would have been
brushed under the rug however this
meeting went really well and i now have
some hope that corrective action will
happen
my daughter thinks the world are the
teacher and i
and has raved about her so it's not that
i want her to get fired that would
devastate my daughter i don't want to
make a horrible situation worse but she
is struggling with this i hope that you
will reach out to me to let me know how
you can help thank you thank you miss
evans for taking time to come to the
board meeting miss batista
and then after miss bautista we have
jennifer k
kiligani thank you welcome she loves my
skirt i love it too it's not mine but i
borrowed it
so um diana batista for the record so i
do want to talk about a lot of just the
mental health issues that we kind of
talked about when the shutdown happens a
lot of our kids when they were isolated
at home they really saw an impact and so
we i think we're all kind of
acknowledging that my concern is is once
many of our kids went back to school and
it was prior to the pandemic um many of
our kids were still sitting alone so
whether that was in the lunchroom or
secluded in a classroom or whatever it
might be
my kids unfortunately have
have been the kids that are sitting
alone at lunch thankfully my son when he
went back to school my youngest little
guy
when he went back to school in march he
had kind of noticed and it surprises me
sometimes i think that our staff don't
always notice
um but he had walked into the lunchroom
and he had seen another student that was
sitting at the allergy table
and he understood the chad hit or the
child had allergy issues um he does too
so he understands it and he respects
that but he had asked you know mom can
you make me a gluten-free something
without peanut butter so that i can sit
with this child this child is sitting
alone on a daily basis
and so he went and he did that he's been
doing that since he came back to school
and i'm so proud of him but i just i i
kind of wonder how many of us as
trustees staff on the school board how
many of us have gone into the schools
post pandemic and gone into the
lunchrooms and seen or seen how many
kids are sitting alone on a daily basis
and i just the reason why i bring it to
your attention is i understand that you
can't take action on an agenda but you
can under operations and so mister
jara you know i'm going to hold you
accountable
but i would love if we can get some sort
of volunteer program moving forward for
many of our kids so that when they are
in the lunchroom or they are anywhere if
they're sitting alone and we have
children that are willing to sit with
them whether they have food allergies
they have autism anything that kind of
impacts the socialization that we really
take that into consideration and just do
something moving forward that's really
positive for our kids so um we know that
there's been an impact with behavior and
i think that that would really help them
support it so i just wanted to recommend
that thank you
thank you miss bautista appreciate your
comment uh jennifer
kilikini
jennifer president now president
mr gonzalez ed gonzalez
and after ed we have room for maybe two
more individuals
um
miss comroe and um chuck
summers chuck summers yes
thank you madam vice chair members of
the board uh superintendent jara um
normally i come in here and you hear who
i represent today i'm gonna i would wear
too many hats i'm just gonna speak as an
individual first of all i do appreciate
i've seen almost half of the trustees
this week um i've been putting on
working with some forms actually here
where the visions are so i do appreciate
everybody coming
and then superintendent joe i do
appreciate the updates that you've given
us about
the health clinic over at bailey middle
school i know you spoke to our chair
after nevada talks about and so we have
not come back to you with some
information but we will be in contact so
we do appreciate you following up on to
that but the reason i'm actually here
today was more about some of the
comments that was made by district staff
at a workshop at the department of
education at ab469
i think the thing that i find troubling
is i know this board has talked about
trying to work with the state board
we've heard that from many members but
the language i was used from the
district was saying and i'm gonna use
the word defamatory about saying that
this district isn't following the law to
me that doesn't look like trying to work
together with people
it is i'm gonna say it's rather shocking
um
you know it's been six years next month
the law was passed or seven years six
months in october
um when the regulations were passed but
the idea that the reason the state board
is taking such strong action is because
movement hasn't been happening this long
and it started with the previous
superintendent it started with the
previous board this item was passed
before and if you guys said on this
committee maybe lola brooks was the
exception when they were going through
that process but for the most part when
they talk about doing harsh languages
they want movement from the district and
when i heard things going well we're not
really enforcing the law or they're
being misrepresented the law hasn't been
implemented and so people are trying to
figure out how to get that to happen i'm
not going to make a big deal about it
i'm not going to sit here and throw a
hat
you know i'm trying to have civil
conversations i think for the last week
we have proven we can have community
events
talk about education where people are
not shouting yelling at each other
because that's what we need we need to
have common sense
conversations and something where people
can talk about it so we can actually get
stuff done
so thank you madam vice president i
appreciate the time
thank you ed thank you mr gonzalez miss
camaro
and after miss conroe we have mr chuck
summers
sarah calmer for the record
these students are our future yet when
they speak it often falls on deaf ears
and why because they're young because
they don't have 30 years of experience
because it has always been done one way
well guess what
youth bring fresh ideas the experiences
and accomplishments of this generation
are amazing
and maybe the way it has always been
done is the wrong way
i did not plan to come on speak here on
this tonight but my student marisol who
spoke earlier asked for my support and i
am here to give it wholeheartedly she
comes here with a request but also with
a growth mindset and a look towards
solutions for any possible concern
that may cause you to deny the class of
2022 and all classes going forward the
ability to wear a cultural heritage and
identity-based graduation items
we spend 12 years telling them to be
their own person to look into themselves
and be the best them that they can be
and then at the end we tell them to
shove everything we've been hitting them
over the head with down
fall in line
um i'm sorry and fall in line i'm proud
to call marisol my student and i truly
hope that you very quickly because
graduation is approaching
find a way to let marisol show what she
is proud of as she walks across that
stage on june 1st thank you
thank you miss conroe thank you for
refraining from
thank you audience for repeating from
clapping
mr chuck
welcome
good evening board
and i appreciate this time to speak my
peace
i worked for the district for 35 years
my wife has been teaching for 50 years
in southern nevada
my family has been
supportive of the district in every way
the one thing that i find troubling
these days is a matter of trust and
respect
as an employee
i waited until my 34th year
to list any concerns
with the superintendent
and the response i got was a very short
hang in there
before i retired i left a letter
to the superintendent concerned
uh with my concerns for how maintenance
was being run
and how the employees were being
for lack of a better word
abused as people
and disrespected
and not trusted for what they do
i got no response
i wrote a letter to this board
with the same concerns
again i got no response
now while the district has been good to
me for 35 years
i was
overwhelmed by the fact that people just
don't trust or respect and i've seen it
happen with this board
and we wonder why
our children are having a rough time in
school
we wonder why our employees are leaving
the district
in busloads
it's because every level of our
establishment is not doing
we're living up to the trust
and to the respect that we've asked of
them
thank you
thank you for your time
at this time ladies and gentlemen we'd
like to
move on
um
we have moving on to the consent agenda
we have some public comment on consent
start from the top
the first with the individuals who
registered in advance
we have jamie odinski
jamie i see you on
perfect after jamie
i have miss bautista
and
after miss bautista i have adam tampa
tampa
welcome
okay i'm jamie tedrinski for the record
i wrote about half of my comments in
advance so
we all might be surprised tonight
um
[Music]
so last meeting was a little bit of a
doozy which is why i signed up for 3.01
minutes from the last agenda
because i want to comment specifically
on
the meeting from two weeks ago
we made national news again
and again it's for the wrong reasons
but when you have enough parents you
don't have kids in the district
screaming insanity at our board meetings
it's bound to make its way onto reddit
and other social media platforms
um so let's get an education tonight
because i'm going to share some
definitions with the crowd
um libel it's a published false
statement that is damaging to a person's
reputation uh slander it's an action or
crime of making a false spoken statement
damaging to a person's reputation and
defamation the action of damaging the
good reputation of someone forgive me
jamie are you speaking about the
minutes from the last board meeting yes
and then i'm moving into i think i'm
sorry yeah that's uh
the minutes of the that are on the
consent agenda are actually for february
28th and march 2nd so okay okay just
stand in mind okay thank you thank you
um okay so all of that then was
committed at our meeting two weeks ago
um all that's been recorded all that's
been sent to a legal team um because a
group who calls themselves mama bears
needs to be stopped um i really enjoyed
the comments though um they called me
the ccsd poster child and the ccsd
mascot um so i brought a costume tonight
um i also
looked up how much
a mascot makes
um
it's a little bit more than what i make
as a
10-year teacher
with two master's degree a third one in
the works
i'm in the process of becoming a
nationally board certified teacher
i know there's a bingo card out there
tonight talking about how much i'm going
to talk about myself so they can check
that off right now um
from amazon to internet to your public
comment well i love your flag i'd like
for you to please continue with your
comment thank you um
so
i just want to kind of put that on we
definitely are underpaid as educators in
nevada so we should fix that um the next
one i want to talk about 303 the mou
with the united citizens foundation um
this is an excellent thing if you
haven't read it in the minutes i suggest
people go and read it
several people have been speaking for
months about the needs in our school for
mental health care um the only real
questions i have and i know you can't
respond directly right now i just kind
of want to put it out there for future
consideration
i hope someone can look into why it's
only 15 schools which is what the
agreement is for um there's over 300
campuses in ccsd i know it's not
possible to
roll this out to 300 schools at once
but i wonder what the criterion is to be
chosen like how are those 15 schools
going to be chosen it's a two-year
program so is it designed to be renewed
um and will 15 new schools be chosen
next may since the first 15 will be
chosen this may um so if we could get
answers to those questions in a
subsequent board meeting um i think the
community kind of deserves that mental
health clearly is um
an issue and i've been called mentally
ill yeah i am i'm standing here on a
flag when i could be home with my cats
having a microwave dinner okay because
that's also what they say
um warrants 3.05
so you might be wondering why i brought
up warrants
on page four my name is listed with a
675
tuition reimbursement so thank you for
that
genuinely i mean thank you for that um
it was from the rpdp library and media
program so thanks to rpdp i've been a
certified school librarian since january
it's really exciting i encourage
teachers if that program is offered
again
to do it takes about a year at seven
classes you really learn a lot
one of the lessons we had was about how
to bind books for distribution in our
library and another on how to access the
resources across the district
the district uses a program called
destiny discover through fullet and you
can actually access every library in
ccsd
if you know how to use it and any school
librarian and all school should have a
librarian because of policies
should know how to do that so that means
we can look at what books are and aren't
in ccsd and because they came with props
tonight
i brought a book from our library um
and since this is a huge issue
i asked my librarian for the gayest book
we possessed um and she gave it to me
lgbtq rights and activism because it's
something that our kids need to know um
but you'll notice a couple of things um
there's a process for how we put the
call number on books every ccsd library
book has to have this call number every
ccsd library book has to have
the code like there's literally a very
specific process to do this or it can't
be in the library and again any
librarian can tell you that um so when
we have people who
come to the board meeting with
photocopies of books that they claim are
in the library if it's really in the
library they can go check it out their
kid can check it out um if it's really
in the library literally anyone who has
a ccsd email can look up any book
that is in the system and is not in the
system and i think we need to be really
cautious of the fact that you have bad
actors coming and accusing our
librarians of having something that
don't exist um
what is that reference to when it comes
to the consent
okay
and then 3.6 and 3.7
i'm going to kind of combine those it's
the licensed personnel unified personnel
we know that we're hemorrhaging staff um
i know this you know this the nation
knows this four thousand dollars truly
isn't enough to move here when they see
the abuse played out on their screens
i know tons of great teachers who are
leaving the profession entirely
um when i came here in 2015 they offered
us five thousand dollars
um and even then people are like well
that's not really enough right it was
enough for me to get out here but it
wasn't enough for a lot of people but
now it's offering four thousand now the
criterion has changed like they have to
be dedicated be here at least two years
i don't think it's going to work um i
know plenty of great teachers who are
leaving i know teachers who were going
to be here tonight who found themselves
last minute not being able to be here
but i think it's really time that we
take a seriously serious look at what
it's going to take to keep teachers here
because it's not bringing new teachers
in for four thousand dollars when
nationwide teacher programs are ending
because there's not enough students to
go into those programs um it's not
enough when we constantly see our pay
frozen or when the cu system is so
difficult to navigate that people give
up and can't access their raises when
they're putting in the educational work
to get those raises
i think we really need to
look at that i think we need to look at
who is coming and speaking against
teachers at these meetings who think
because they have kids that they're an
educational expert all right i think we
need to put look at what is being put
out online what is being allowed to be
said in this board room and in the lobby
of this building and in the bathrooms of
this building because your teachers are
under attack
and
and we're leaving you know like it's
it's not
it's not worth it to
have
my children's advocate tell me to kill
myself in the bathroom
um so last thing i know we're almost out
of time um one of my friends she was
sick she couldn't make it she emailed
you um so it's in the it's in the board
documents already
um i think we need to be
really aware
um that when
a person gets thrown out of this board
room because they're screaming about
genitalia that we don't have a trustee
taking pictures with them the next day
because it's tradition
in reference to danny mr
thank you for your time
at this time i'd like to invite miss
batista back to the
podium to speak on we have five items
batista
[Music]
any chance i get to be super silly i
appreciate it forgive me spaties i need
to correct something i mentioned autumn
would be next but it's actually jessica
um allen and then miss tampa
thank you
interesting because i saw the paper and
the paper had me next but i will allow
it
yes you are you are next you are next i
met after you it is jessica and then
miss tampa then i apologize you're okay
thank you for
keeping us accountable i will own it
when i am wrong i am wrong and i will
own it nope uh allow us one moment while
we restart your time sure thank you
welcome
um diana batista special education
advocate for the record um
3.04 i have a concern so the approval
process phase three um i would
appreciate if any trustee could maybe
clarify whether or not there was a
mention of cameras and surveillance um
but they didn't specify where
and so i know that we have cameras just
about anywhere i know that there are
some updates sometimes we have cameras
that don't work really conveniently
typically when our kids are getting
abused unfortunately but it does come up
um and so in the event that we are
looking at cameras and classrooms i want
to ensure that we are looking at
ensuring that it's everywhere so um i
absolutely support our staff members
being safe 100 i think that's really
important we want to keep our staff here
we want to ensure that they're safe um
in addition to that too though i
wouldn't ensure that our children are
also kept in the back of our minds that
when we're looking at these things we're
looking at not just staff safety but
student safety also
there wasn't clarification on that so i
wasn't sure if anybody could maybe ask
that
um the other thing
3.05
as i was going through the warrants and
bills payable i see on page four ccsd
finally paid jamie todrinsky for a copy
of the gay agenda well i think the
reimbursement was quite low considering
all the things we could learn from the
gay agenda such as love always wins and
suicide prevention i do hope to see the
reimbursement increases and we see the
gay agenda in all ccsd libraries very
soon
um also 3.17 i noticed on page one
we have an issue with the establishment
clause so i don't know if you guys have
looked into that but there was 9 200
that went to the association of
christian schools
um shocker i found it i know you hate my
guts but i did
um
this is going to software for schools
so when reading the association's
mission statement it exists to
strengthen christian schools and
christian educators well why
or worldwide you might want to review
that so again establishment clause that
was concerning for me i think that needs
to be reviewed as to why it is that
we're spending 9 200 of federal dollars
that is going to a christian
organization
so we are federal dollars we have
public schools typically that's for
private i don't know why that's going
there but it is
so 3.18 um purchase award in the amount
of 60 i'm sorry 640 000 for rethink ed
to address many supports for students
with autism
um would cost you zero dollars if we
just got the rbts and bcbas that i have
talked about over and over and over
again
um
we can go and we can improve software
and programs and things over and over
and i do think it's important for our
teachers and our staff but the problem
is while we're going and we're approving
all of these programs we're not
addressing the other barriers in the
classroom that are going on so when our
children have behavior issues and we've
you know reduced the links department
who by the way are not licensed to rbts
like some of our privates are
we're doing all of these things we're
approving program and program and
program and we're not looking at why it
is
our children are not learning and a lot
of this is barriers such as behavior
that's going on in the classroom just
many different things we need to address
what these barriers are
and so if we can get rbts that are going
to cost us zero dollars and not be
hitting our budget so much i would love
if we could do that um i think that's
definitely the board's mission from what
i've looked at over the last few months
really important again we just want to
ensure that we are getting the behavior
under control
also
3.28 so lots of agenda items for
professional services and architectural
design agreements to review inspect and
modify all these school sites but i've
come and spoken before the board again
um over and over again about the variety
hotbox and the illegal seclusion
enclosures that are going on i know they
spoke to you about it several months ago
i do notice that of all the school sites
that are looking at being reviewed
modified looking at the design
architecture all of the above variety is
not in there so as an action item i
would like to add or see variety added
in there so what is going on at variety
and these illegal seclusion enclosures
are absolutely illegal it's a major just
um federal violation i don't know why we
have not looked at it why we're not
taking that more seriously but it is an
issue we've had it is literally made
that the news all the way to washington
d.c
so we've been three years behind the
behind kind of what's going on and again
i know i've talked about it but that has
still not been addressed
um also 3.47
so we have 390 000 that looks like um is
in a settlement agreement for due
process i fully support it i think a lot
of our children unfortunately are not
receiving a free and appropriate public
education
it affects not only our students it
affects every other student in the
classroom it affects our teachers it
affects the entire classroom environment
school environment all of the above
so if we aren't going to provide faith i
fully support the 390 000 and that's it
thank you
thank you ms bautista
jessica allen you have two items
jessica allen is not present
okay we're going to move on to miss
autumn tampa who has one item
you have two items
thank you miss tampa
and then um we're going to move on to
yellow cards after miss tampa we have
sarah comroe and
nicolas
oh forgive me it's just sarah calmer for
now
thank you mr taba welcome
thank you autumn tampa speaking as an
individual
um i'm glad that we've got a few new
employees coming on as opposed to a
whole bunch leaving it's kind of nice to
see
i've been here a long time i've
experienced working with
and near and around
a lot of different
a lot of different principals and
administrators because i've was working
as a substitute teacher first in over
150 schools
and then after that i was an ell tester
and i worked in 160 schools during that
job and that's because we went to
different schools for the testing yearly
and so i've had a lot of experience
i recently have a new principal at a
school that i'm now being surplused out
of
who is really very unique
and when i first met him we kind of
butted heads but as we got to know each
other
his whole attitude and disposition and
the way that he communicates with
children and adults
is very very refreshing
and i guess that that's what i'm trying
to say is that i have noticed that i
would say at least 80 percent of the
administrators that i have communicated
with and dealt with
most of my career i've pushed my way
through but most of my career have um
almost like a script that they follow in
their responses to you as an employee
and i'm sure that they have a script
they follow in responses to children and
i think other people have touched on
that
and um
that whole perspective needs to change
not just the culture for employees but
the culture for employees is the same
one that administrators have for
children
and there needs to be an openness and
acceptance that everybody has talked
about here in so many different ways
and
the rigidity the regimentation it needs
to be let go you know if kovid taught us
anything
it was that
life is short and precious
and being in a school and being live
with people and learning is a gift
and we're missing it we're going back to
all the old ways and you know we're
connecting it now to teachers you've got
teachers leaving instead of teachers
being hired i don't know what vast
numbers in may it's going to happen but
there's 1500 teachers
positions open and about 600 support
staff i don't know how many
administrators because that doesn't show
up on my um
my job job thing but
that's a serious problem that's a
serious problem and i think it can be
fixed with all of the different things
that we here have been saying but
we keep banging our heads against the
wall
and maybe some of you listen but there's
not a concerted effort there's not a
joint massive effort to hear
what people are saying to you
and and i think the parents some of them
they have their emotions the other some
some groups but a lot of parents have
concerns we're all partners we're all
together in this no one is way up here
as far as their humanness we are all
human beings we all have hearts and
souls we all have gifts talents
abilities we're all unique individuals
and we should all be respected for that
and that is not happening it's not
happening to teachers it's not happening
with principles it's not happening with
support staff and it's not happening
with students
and i'm seriously concerned i almost
walked out monday i almost quit my job
and i had to take a deep breath because
they can't afford it
and that's happening not just because of
covid but it's happened to me throughout
my career because of the
the lack of kindness the lack of empathy
the lack of upset acceptance that i feel
as a human being and that i see others
feeling i see children feeling and and i
i don't know how else to say it i feel
like i've said it a million times over
but i want to see action i want to see
something being done not just a little
bit social emotional training no more
you need more
thank you
thank you miss tampa
for reminding us of our joint humanity
at this time oh forgive me we have miss
camaro
thank you and
we have four items uh miss camaro we
have 3.06 3.07
3.34 and 3.47
welcome
thank you
sarah comro for the record
um i want to start with 3.34
upgrading the air conditioning at rancho
high school where i work
so awesome very exciting and at the same
time the last time we had work done at
rancho our carpets were replaced in
november
and they broke large amounts of stuff in
my class worth hundreds of dollars
that i had been told to leave where it
was because it was unwieldy
and then i was told for months that they
would replace it
and then they didn't so while we're
approving all these people to come in
and do work i just ask that we make sure
that they're not jerk faces who break
stuff and then don't replace it after
they promise to
um moving on to 3.47 another special
education settlement which seems to be
the
super fun run of the mill here
if you took all the money that you spend
on settlements and all the money that
you spend building up a wall of lawyers
that you use to infringe on the rights
of your special education students and
take away their services
and i don't know spent that money on
actually providing a good and fair
education for these kids
then maybe we would actually have a
successful school district
speaking of special education i want to
look at 3.18 and the amazingly silly and
wonderful miss diana batista
um
was talking about the rethink ed
purchase
and how we need to look at the causation
so when we do
stuff in classrooms in special education
classrooms we do something called abc
you look at the antecedent then you look
at the behavior and then you look at the
consequence and it helps you
to see
why it happened
what we can change or how we can support
to better it but we're not doing that as
a district instead like she said we are
just purchasing this purchasing that
slap a band-aid on but if we pause and
we really looked at what the the problem
is what the antecedent is what the thing
that is happening is the behavior and
then the consequence which is we're
having these struggles
then we would be able to actually find
solutions that are working as opposed to
just putting a little band-aid on a
giant open gaping wound
um and taking that and kind of swinging
it up into 3.06 and 3.07 in conjunction
with 3.18
teacher health trust actually just
dropped services for autistic kids
from
their teachers being able to get
services for our kids and so instead of
costing ten dollars per service it now
costs
150 dollars and these are services that
kids often need daily five days a week
um i know when my son was getting it he
was going to school full day and then
going home and doing three hours a night
i can't afford a hundred and fifty
dollars a day five days a week four
weeks a month
because i'm a teacher in clark county
school district i can't even afford to
give five dollars worth of change to my
students when they ask
um
and so i think you really need to think
about that because these kids they're
not
it's not just that these kids are human
beings which i know some of you up on
that day as may not look at special
education kids that way is what it seems
uh by your statements on social media
but
um they are they're human beings but so
are their parents
right
um and they are we are all trying to
work hard for this district
and we can't do that if our kids are not
being supported and by the way they're
your kids too because they are clark
county school district students who are
now regressing in speech regressing in
behaviors because for one month they are
not able to get services because you
don't pay us enough to pay 150 per
service
and let you yet you let our health
insurance falter to the point where they
no longer cover these necessary services
for our children
to be clear our children because they're
yours too
um and then
now on to the actual speech i wrote for
3.06 and 3.07
to discuss some of the reasons why clark
county school district employees are
fleeing into the wind
in my class i spend a lot of time and
effort creating a welcoming class
culture
my students know that they can come to
me for anything and about anything
they know that i will support them and
work with them to make sure that they
are safe healthy and um and happy as
possible and that they are able to
access their education
to top it off i painstakingly decorate
my room with affirmations positivity and
things that signify it as a safe and
supportive space for all students oh no
i forgot the thing
um one of my peers brought
uh me these because i they knew that i
would know
um who would appreciate them
it is a rainbow sticker to put on our
door that says safe space
oops
i thought to myself i should bring one
for you all here and then i realized
this isn't a safe space
this isn't a safe space for our students
this isn't a safe space for our staff
this isn't a safe space for families or
community members
this wasn't a safe space last june for
our students of color as you all allowed
racism to be amplified for hours on end
this wasn't a safe space last meeting as
you allowed a homophobic and transphobic
comment uh to be thrown around the the
boardroom including a freshman
in the student section being called the
f slur by an audience member that have
repeatedly showed disdain for the
decorum supposedly required in this room
this hasn't been a safe space for as far
back as i can remember while we all hear
you repeatedly misgender and use
incorrect titles for lgbtq plus staff to
come to speak
it's mix tadrinsky and their pronouns
are they them
which by the way you misused literally
90 seconds after they
said that they were thankful that their
admin used the correct honorific and
pronouns last meeting
anyways
displaying this sign
here in this room would be false
advertising and there's no amount of
lipstick we can put on this pig to make
people think it's pretty in here thank
you
our next
ladies and gentlemen i don't want to
have to remind the audience that this is
well i appreciate the encouragement that
takes place through applause it is um
inappropriate
uh we have miss uh
excuse me shantae marshall
uh speaking on 3.02
thank you
welcome
thank you good afternoon everybody
i wanted to speak tonight as you know
i'm the co-founder of 1865 no racism in
schools and we do often receive
rapid requests for response and advocacy
as it pertains to
expulsions
and i am not here to bash anybody
tonight
what i'm here to do is to provide
solutions okay
number one 1865 is going to be
sponsoring along with levassian national
action network las vegas
canvassing for kids on june 11th and i
am asking for every last one of the
trustees to participate in canvassing in
your respective districts
because
we need to get out and gain commitment
from the families we will be equipping
the people with
resource lists as they encounter a need
and they knock at those doors
and the purpose is to reduce the
expulsions and the behaviors that are
happening inside of the schools if we
can talk to the parents meet the needs
of the parents and gain their commitment
or guardians to
the the safety in schools next year we
are ahead of the curve i also want to
just um and i see
it's 41 seconds so i'll try to be quick
but
i want to encourage us to take a moment
to re-center our focus
performance-driven outcomes have been
absent from many conversations
post-pandemic it is imperative that we
go back to the various plans and
policies already implemented and that we
assess what we are truly capable of as a
district at this point
then create a strategy that is effective
and able to drive quantifiable data that
has positive outcomes in the area of
student achievement
in addition to that we have
opportunities where we will continue to
mitigate the conversations that are not
tied to monthly performance metrics
i'll send the email thank you very much
thank you
thank you to shanti i appreciate your
time
at this time i don't see any more uh
yellow cards for
it looks like we may have yes i see that
i see that it's okay
no you're good we have a miss binder for
one two three four
um come on up welcome
we didn't mean to miss you but we're
thank you for bringing
um the attention welcome
um madame president members of the board
dr jorah good evening
if i cry i win bingo
so um
because i was put up to the challenge
this evening before i left the house i
came up with lots of thoughts on our
consent agenda i also have a couple on
four four items on the 4.0 item so i'll
see you back in a few minutes too
oh okay licensed person now
um
saw i think the channel 8 news article
today that a particular middle school
principal
tried to hire three of our j-1 teachers
to throw some vacancies in her school
and was told that she could not do that
really concerning since we have so many
outgoing and if we have some willing to
come and help teach our students that we
probably should prioritize hiring them
but um
not my business maybe the new chief of
hr you know for 200 000 a year can
figure that out for us
um
3.08 um
all of my children
constantly relay that the food sucks
they'll be coming over the summer when
they're not busy with school to vent
their entire feelings about that
but i just figured with all those pretty
agreements going out there that um
and i and i see comments out in the
community a lot that we should just get
the choice of having the pebt benefits
and feed our own children
versus you guys trying to um
scour all the disgusting stuff that
probably gets thrown away
uh 3.18 i did want to hit the speech
language otpt
but uh kind of from a different angle
so i just had my youngest son's annual
iep
and i went back and matched up his vlogs
compared to his speech logs as you guys
know for two years in a row now he has
not received his speech minutes
so i wasn't shocked to find that none of
the dates that the speech therapist
logged in her attorney's notes billing
that um coordinated with any document in
my son's journal of when he actually
went to speech therapy
so when i called that out i wish i would
have taken a picture of the speech
ladies face
um i did give her a lot of grace that we
all make mistakes
and thankfully my son has made
improvement but um
i really just don't know where to go
because they were gonna try to push him
into almost full
gin at first grade next year
despite all of the assessments saying he
could not be even in a kindergarten
classroom so thankfully great principal
um so i hope maybe one year you know
he's got what like 11 years left maybe
one year he'll actually get his services
um
i also though wanted to point out that
in the the last reportable mac audits
that i received
because i'm super curious about services
that are um
billable back to medicaid right i talk
about this a lot like we should be
getting reimbursed for services like
language therapy that we are awarding to
a third party company so we have 6.6
million going for speech language
therapy and we have another just shy of
8.4 million going for ot and pt for kids
who
aren't even getting services
but if you go back to the last quarter
ending june 2021 of your mac audit
excuse me one second i want to be very
very accurate when i report this
total sped expenditures
oh i'm sorry september 21st 2021 quarter
ending total expenditures were about
66.5 million dollars
total claimable was only about 882 000.
so how are we awarding
like
13 million dollars for outside services
and we're only getting
what back
so i think this goes back to where we
constantly talk about data
because i know you have to report data
to get those reimbursed so i'm still
digging and i will keep you apprised of
what i find
um 3.51 um our new chief hr lady
miss tulks i'm not sure if i'm
pronouncing that correctly
um
is from brevard right florida
sued her previous district
um over alleged sexual
allegations from a trustee member so
thankfully we have no men on our board
right now
um
also has claims of retaliation all kinds
of things
and i really just thought like why would
she come here like why
are we setting ourselves up for another
lawsuit because it's all over the place
here and she's inclined to be a
whistleblower so i do like that about
her so i look forward to her future
claims
um
let's see actually that's all i have
thank you so much
our last public
commenter on
uh
consent agenda items is mr david corman
david
trustee williams you're in the queue is
that um
when we're it's okay
no worries i know i thought thank you
you're fine there thank you welcome good
evening thank you
garcia morales and other trustees
superintendent hara
i'm david coleman candidate for district
f i want to discuss the 3.51 employment
agreement for the chief human resources
officer and it got hit by somebody else
right before me here so it was a nice
swaying for me
uh if you remember last past tuesday
night there is a district f candidate
form at windmill mar our windmill
library
i hope that the trustees don't have the
same mindset as trustee ford when she
made her comment to the question by
tiffany
this is specifically about um 3.51 i'd
like for you to keep your comments
specific to that thank you
all right um
she made a comment that's that stated
a comment that stated
something about there is no problem with
with um
employees or employ there is no problem
with employees in the district and we
know that that's not true
we know that the many employees are
leaving this year
the net result is from that all of our
teachers leaving this year is that
they're going to be continuing to fall
behind
and are basically in last in the in
academically
so we all know that uh cs ccsd has to
change their mindset i know that the
majority of you on this board don't
think that way you think that our
employees are important and that they
need to be so that this person who's
coming in
uh dr tulle she's going to be
responsible for all human resources and
all the processes and plot and
procedures within
therefore i hope you guys took the time
to possibly
look at her background because it is
critical
it's a critical decision and it's going
to make it's probably the biggest
decision this board is going to make
for you here as well as probably what
has happened in the last 16 years of of
ccsd i hope you took the time to to go
back and research do your due diligence
as to her background
and as talking to
dr hara as well because they work
together in florida
i hope you did your due diligence and
and i thank you for your time thank you
david
at this time do we have a motion to
adopt the consent agenda i see trustee
williams in the queue
thank you madam vice president at this
time i'd like to make a motion to adopt
the consent agenda
thank you do we have a second
i second
we have a motion by trustee williams a
second by trustee guzman
trustees please cast your vote
trustee brooks
hi
that motion passes
i do that again six to zero noting that
trustee
president zepeda is absent today
thank you very much trustees
we are now moving on to
[Music]
the warrants
trustee brooks
are you available to read the warrants
i am
uh ratified warrants as listed in the
bills payable transmittal and board
memorandum number 18-21-22
in the total amount of 125 million three
hundred ninety thousand four hundred
ninety eight dollars and sixteen cents
thank you trustee brooks
at this time we're gonna move on to 4.01
focus 2024 strategic plan update on
chronic absenteeism
and i see that dr martin is joining us
dr along with dr anzalone welcome thank
you so much for being here this evening
gentlemen we will turn the presentation
over to you and then we'll have public
comment
thank you very much
thank you madam vice president members
of the board dr jarrah
this evening we are providing an update
according to our focus 2024 strategic
plan again the board has seen this
presentation in previous forms and i'll
go to get to the dates where you saw
previous updates
but again this aligns to student success
and specifically safety and engagement
chronic absenteeism and so this is
aligned to again uh the focus 2024 plan
which is made up of several components
for accountability
and again as a refresher trustees there
have been multiple presentations in the
last several years on chronic
absenteeism
uh the latest being on february 10 2022
when we provided an update uh regarding
semester one chronic absenteeism rates
uh with your permission madam vice
president
uh i'll turn it over to dr ann's law
absolutely welcome good evening vice
president morales members of the board
dr jarrah
john anzalone assistant superintendent
esd for the record
um just a refresher as the the
definition that we follow for chronic
absenteeism chronic absenteeism is a
school quality measure on the nevada
school performance framework that
captures the total percentage of
students who are absent for 10
or more of their enrolled days
our theory of action has stayed
consistent
we believe that if we identify root
causes for missed school
situations and use outside partners to
assist with chronic absentee efforts
then we will increase connectedness on
campuses
so here in front of you you see a
breakdown of our student groups
the data
shows that we're continuing to see
increases in our chronic absenteeism
essentially across the board
with one bright spot in our black
african american student group where
there was a one percent
decrease over time
and you can take a look at that
and also looking at our targets
we are we haven't hit our targets for
this year
we're above our targets in all areas
with our brightest spot being our asian
student group
with a 20
actual target
our chronic absenteeism gap overall
results and status this is the gap
between the highest and lowest student
groups in chronic absenteeism in
percentage points our target was 9.3
percent and currently we're at 28
in that gap
looking at um like district districts um
within our state and across the country
um currently we are on par with other
like districts um so we're not alone in
this um if you look at denver and
miami-dade um we're just about the same
as them as far as our percentages um and
interestingly enough washoe county um is
is a little bit higher um than ours
right now
so again this shows that this is not
just a statewide problem or a district
problem but a nationwide problem
so what are some of our challenges our
successes and lessons learned
we know that we're still
in the distance ed aftermath and and so
the challenges are in that area as well
as
absence reporting consistency across the
board our successes we have strong
partnerships as you know and they're
very very willing to support we've been
working very collaboratively with them
and also we have targeted support during
the school closure and our attendance
officers have done a phenomenal job and
we've increased
our employees in that in that department
lessons learned we obviously have seen
that chronic absenteeism impacts all
indicators across the board
and our recovery from increased rates
will require ongoing comprehensive
initiatives
which we'll share with you here on this
next slide so our next steps
as you know beginning in april and
continuing through the rest of this
school year into june
we've been having our student focus
groups feedback sessions we're calling
student voices it's been an outstanding
opportunity for us to as our team has
met with students across the valley and
all the trustee
districts
we found some emerging themes
we have found that students really like
attendance incentives and they like for
many of those to come back and and i
think we heard from a student today that
mentioned that as well
we know that students are asking for
strong tier one instruction engaging
lessons that will
entice them to come to school and be
more motivated and of course
connectedness we've talked about that
before connectedness with
one or more adults on campus
our students have mentioned that they
have goals and dreams they like to come
to school however
life has happened
family matters work we've talked to
students that actually help provide
medical attention to their parents and
grandparents and so they stay home to
provide pills and other medications for
the families
they also seem to have adult priorities
right now which i'm sure we can
empathize with
students like little things like
welcomes and good mornings things that
we may take for granted sometimes and
positive reinforcements throughout the
day and again connecting to at least one
or more adults on campus
we will continue our work with the
truancy prevention outreach program or
t-pop we feel like we continue to have a
strong relationship and partnership with
the county
specifically t-pop
we've provided additional staff using
grant fundings
and again the five harbors have been an
outstanding uh talking point for us and
we've used them um throughout the
district and throughout the valley my
brother's keeper and sjp school justice
partnership have also been outstanding
partnerships in this area
and lastly we plan in august uh in the
fall to continue to provide
differentiated attendance reporting pl
for our clerks and registrars which has
already begun and onboarding anybody new
coming on so they can understand the
attendance coding process
in a comprehensive way
dr barton
madam vice president members of the
board dr jarrah that concludes our
presentation just to highlight what the
data included this evening again this is
an update through uh quarter three uh we
will be coming back to the board with a
cumulative uh look at the entire school
year regarding chronic absenteeism and
we're we're happy to address any
questions you may have this evening
thank you dr barton thank you dr
anthelon
this time i'm going to turn it over to
trustees i see trustee williams is in
the
forgive me thank you so much for that
reminder
trustee guzman we have a couple of
before we go on to questions we have
some
public comments we'll start with
individuals who have registered in
advance and that is
autumn tampa
and we
have 4.01 chronic absenteeism
and then we have miss binder
thank you welcome
autumn tampa speaking as an individual
just so you know i was sick for two
weeks and then i was sick a couple
months ago for two weeks so i'm still
being careful
um
you know i i was really surprised to see
this um on the agenda i know um did you
hit the time button
i said i could use the extra time
um
i never get any so
anyways um prior to kovid there was a
problem with absenteeism and i know that
i did speak about that a few times i
know i lived in an apartment complex
with a family the father worked nights
in a band and the mother worked days
as a maid so she had to leave the house
at seven o'clock and i usually left
around the same time
and if the husband didn't come home from
his night work then the junior high
students stayed home to take care of the
toddler
so i mean there wasn't really any other
answer survival was what was important
and
i you know i i keep mentioning because
during the recession
a lot of services were cut for aid for
families in need for child care and that
sort of thing
um
i know that even after covet i've had
students say well i had to stay home to
take care of my brother or sister
my mother was sick and i had to take
care of her
so there's all of that i know when i
worked at another junior high school as
long-term sub there was a girl that had
a crush on a boy who was cutting and so
she kept cutting because of him so
there's lots of different reasons why
people cut
um i think the numbers are skewed
because of covid i i'm i couldn't
believe that we were even calculating
numbers because i don't want sick
children coming to school they get me
sick
and now i've got children afraid to go
to the nurse because they don't want to
get in trouble for going home
so i don't know what the district is
going to do
because to me it's a nationwide problem
we'll go to school go to work if you're
sick it's okay tough it out
i think that's the wrong answer because
you get everybody else sick and you hurt
your body
so i don't know there should be a focus
of getting kids who are not sick into
school but not making kids who are sick
come to school so numbers are up and
that's the serious problem that i see
and have seen for the whole time i've
been in the district thank you
thank you miss tampa
at this time i'd like to invite miss
binder to come up to speak on 4.01
looks like we also have miss camro
on 4.01 and miss camilla by watters
welcome back thank you
madam president members of the board dr
jarrah
um
so i've been talking about this for like
a year
uh
i cannot wait to see the actual data on
why kids are missing school
over
the course of next week there will be
several truancy graduations happening
across your campuses
and these are kids that we've had the
pleasure of mentoring
getting to come to school
getting them to believe in themselves to
raise them above passing
and for a lot of these students the new
grading um system worked out really well
for them
what's very concerning in in the
presentation is that
46.7
of those chronically absent were our iep
kids
so now we have a whole bunch of money
going out the door to a whole bunch of
kids who aren't getting services and
almost half of them aren't even coming
to school
where's the money
all right let's go thank you miss binder
comes comro sarah camro
and then miss bywater's camilla by
waters
welcome back
thank you thank you
sarah comrade for the record the young
scholar that spoke earlier i believe
named jacob
on the tardy policy impacting chronic
absenteeism
i made a really good point we should be
getting them to want to be on time
earlier um up here they spoke about
positive reinforcement and connecting
them to at least one or two teachers
great ideas if we had the staff to
create that school culture in case you
haven't noticed we're a little low
uh so i just pay my students to be on
time to commemorate cash dollars
um and that's worked really good
but i'm curious what the focus is going
to be next year regarding chronic
absenteeism when we're short and extra i
believe it's 1400 students teachers is
where we're sitting right now
i also wanted to add to this and say
that um
your ssd department your special
education services department
um when they come in
and they assess a child with special
education services
for
a change of placement
or for additional support so higher
levels of support
somebody who has never met that child or
somebody who has only seen that child
for
one hour
gets to make a decision
about that child's placement instead of
the iep team which is the federal
requirement
um
and that is because
the the school is scared of retaliation
and the excuse that they often give
is we cannot support a change of
placement or more supportive services
higher services
because that child has chronic
absenteeism
well when that child had covid
twice last semester
now they have chronic absenteeism and i
think that the teacher that's with them
seven hours a day
multiple days a week even if it's not
all five right
even if they're chronically absent they
still know better so that's a huge
problem we have with the chronic
absenteeism situation thank you so much
thank you miss comroe i'd like to invite
miss
camilla by waters
to the podium
welcome
okay um camila bywater is president of
the las vegas alliance of black school
educators
um so after listening to that
presentation
i noticed that
the only minoritized population that was
announced
were
um for our black students
and i believe i saw the numbers were
kind of blurry and small but i believe i
saw about
48.1 percent
for our black african-american students
um the numbers are definitely high
for our minoritized populations and
including students with disabilities
which is really interesting because
they're not in school that sounds like
some lawsuits right here but um there
has to be an evaluation of how the
programs that we currently have
um are operating and if they're truly
doing the work that we're saying that
they're doing
absenteeism has not
all of a sudden popped up in our
district it has been an issue and it's
only been exacerbated
by the pandemic
so we are asking that
we really look into our partnerships
evaluate the effectiveness of those
programs and determine if they're really
providing the services that we need for
our students because it seems that we
really need some intense services
when i was teaching in ccsd and back in
the day
i often
had conversations with my black students
who often feel alienated and that they
don't have a voice within their
education and oftentimes they struggle
with their white teachers they struggle
with teachers who not understand
their culture their backgrounds and how
who they are impacts their educational
experiences
i would hope that we're incorporating
culturally responsive pedagogies as well
into our practices so that we can
encourage our students to come to school
so they can value themselves by seeing
themselves within the curriculum
and i forgot
thank you camilo bywaters
i have diana bautista who's also signed
up for 4.01
um
batista for the record so i'm a little
bit surprised because this has caught my
attention for months and months and i
i don't even think you guys sometimes
realize the
significance sometimes of the statements
that you make and so months ago we
talked about the chronic
truancy and the fact that in that data i
throw all of that data out i don't trust
any of it and unfortunately a lot of it
is because we're sitting here we're
suspending kids and we're addressing
behavior issues or whatever it might be
and we are then
punishing our kids for behaviors but
then we're also at the same time marking
them as chronically true
and i don't understand why that is
additionally
many of our families which is not
typically discussed or thought about
which surprises me is the fact that many
of our kids who are chronically torrent
may have medical issues
we don't talk about supplemental
services and what that looks like in an
iep and the additional supports and
services that we can offer students who
are chronically truant
my son is one of them that receives
those services i'm very thankful of it
um but i can also tell you that since
he's come back to school he hasn't
gotten one hour of it shocker
um
i don't know where the teachers are
where the staff are that are giving
these services but when we're sitting
here we're looking at these numbers a
lot of times there are extenuating
circumstances that i don't think is
always addressed before the board some
of that is because they are
immunocompromised or they may have
additional medical issues i know that
like my oldest son when my youngest son
is out because he's sick he's afraid
that he's going to go and he's going to
take covet or something else at that
point to his one-to-one aide who is
maybe
um a little bit older and i'm trying to
think of the words here but without
being
i guess offensive
but um so he's you know some of our kids
are they're just afraid they're afraid
that you know because the younger one is
sick i had a teacher that informed me
this morning that they're out sick right
now because of kova they tested positive
this morning my first instinct is when
was the last time that you worked with
my child because i have to worry about
my youngest son who's immunocompromised
so
that's it thank you thank you miss
batista
we have brenda zamora who's also signed
up for 4.01
welcome hello for the record brenda
zamora i just quickly wanted to share as
i was listening to the presentation my
kids story so
as we're hearing you know awarding
children who have perfect attendance it
sounds awesome and everything but
i think about my children who
unfortunately you know the first week
when school started my oldest just went
you know had surgery she was out for two
weeks she was admitted in the hospital
and two weeks after that we got in a
major car accident and we were out for
about a month because i was septic and i
was in the hospital and i just couldn't
help my children get to school at that
point
and i think about them and their
situation of things that they just have
no control about you know this is stuff
that it's not their fault it's nobody's
fault it's just life happens just like
how everyday adults
you know things happen
um and then in december of course we get
coveted so we were out another month so
it's just
she's had 10 surgeries she is immune
compromised you know and i think about
even when she starts a fever she starts
anything i do pull her out of school
because i don't want it to get worse i
don't want you know someone else to
probably who's starting something just
spreading because we all know elementary
school students they they just
full of viruses right and that's
something we all know
um but i think about her
possibly sitting in this attendance you
know certificate ceremony and how she
just
might feel some type of way right and i
just want to let you all know that i
know my story's not the only one as i
talk to people they have similar stories
we just saw a comment about someone who
they had coveted twice this year already
you know so it's just
things that just happen and we just have
to think about that you know as we think
about perfect attendance it's not
you're creating this idea and we have
support staff who don't have paid sick
days either you know who can't take a
sick day off because they can't afford
that day with no pay so it's just so
much that goes into it and i don't like
this idea of you get a certificate for
being perfect that's not what reality is
thank you
thank you miss mora
we have
ariane pritchard
ariana rihanna richard
welcome
it's ariane like marianne without the m
aryan aaron richard for the record
welcome i am a teacher in this district
i'm a 14 year veteran teacher and this
year has been the worst year for
attendance that i have ever experienced
and then the bomb was dropped on my high
school students that next year that they
would start at 7 a.m 45 minutes earlier
than their start time and it's already a
difficult time for them to get to school
i was having students with
transportation issues earlier this year
those seem to have been mitigated
slightly
but when i was covering for another
teacher's class because you know i don't
get a prep
what
the
upperclassmen were saying is well since
school's starting 45 minutes earlier and
classes are 45 minutes long
i'm just gonna miss my whole first
period
so i want to say that that unilateral
operational decision to start nearly
every high school at 7 am
is going to negatively impact
attendance and increased truancy
especially in many of our high schools
thank you so much
at this time we have no more public
comment for 4.01
and i'd like to turn it over to my
colleagues who have questions i see
trustee williams is
in the queue
go ahead
thank you madam vice president thank you
dr angelone and dr barton i have just a
couple questions um
again i'd like to state that
and you guys can
we are not the ones that make up the
definition of chronic absenteeism that's
the state
so i would suggest to parents and
teachers and community members to go
lobby with the legislators and change
the definition because i understand that
life happens and in 2020 and 2021 a lot
of students had to leave school because
they took on jobs because they became
homeless
which for whatever reason
their absenteeism went up and so
that's one of my questions is do you
guys plan on working with the
legislators for the next legislative
session to help change that definition
so it these numbers actually become a
little bit more accurate
oh
dr jarrah
go ahead doctor thank you thank you
madam president members of the board mr
manzie come in um as this is part of how
we assess
and hold schools accountable from the
state department i know there's some
conversations but mr manzi will be
the appropriate staff thank you
welcome thank you
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent greg manzi
assistant superintendent for the record
um we are following the federal guidance
that defines chronic absenteeism so that
is what we're adhering to in terms of
the business rules and the calculations
here um absent is absent and closed
towards the calculation and the 50 or
more for a day
sure i i 100 understand that i guess my
my question was i would hope that the
school district or community members or
anybody that they see this and they
understand that yeah life happens to
some of these students beyond their
control and um i agree that we should we
should incentivize students to come to
school regardless of what's going on but
sometimes they just can't so um that was
one of my questions and then
my question my second question was for
the online students
um do you have a
a rate a truancy rate or an absenteeism
rate that is counting that or
or not you said that was one of your
challenges
go ahead dr martin thank you thank you
madam vice president members of the
board uh superintendent jarrah so the
distance learning
in fact and mr manzi can correct me if
i'm wrong they are counted as present if
they're say quarantined and they're
provided with a distance learning option
they are in fact provided with a present
code
as far as differentiating that from the
overall chronic absenteeism number
that's difficult because the overall
attendance coding is the same for all
attendance factors
sure
okay all right that's all i have
questions for thank you
thank you trustee williams i see trustee
guzman is in the queue
go ahead tracy guzman
thank you
um
i have just a couple of questions i'm
really um happy that uh comro dollars as
an incentive does work and that was in
our presentation so i'm excited about
that
um but
i want to talk about
the bus issues were the bus issues taken
into account for absenteeism
or is it as you just mentioned to
trustee williams that it's just an
absence as an absence
go ahead dr martin thank you madam vice
president members of the board
superintendent trustee guzman to your
question
i know that this year has been a
challenge with with some service
providing with the bus shortage and the
driver shortage uh what we've done as a
district is definitely we we encouraged
our principals working with their teams
that if there was a bus that was
arriving late there would be
leniency as far as
tardies so we definitely
worked with our principals on that we
know that they use sound judgment and if
a bus comes in obviously late it's not
the child's fault so uh that being part
of the calculation uh we we worked with
our principals to ensure as much as it
could that there was leniency for those
factors that were beyond their control
okay thank you
and then the last question that i had
has to do with students that work um
during the pandemic they had to start
working right
what accommodations have we made for
those students so that they're not
absent
go ahead dr martin thank you madam vice
president uh members of the board dr
trusty guzman i think it's a great
question
i don't know if i have a precise answer
because it's a complicated issue right
so i think that um
students that are required to work at a
time that's unprecedented um how do we
accommodate for that with a federal
requirement with chronic absenteeism
right um
to be determined that's why we're doing
these focus groups okay we keep talking
to our students uh dr anslone has
done really good work taking a deep dive
with these students to learn about their
issues and what's preventing them from
coming to school and i think that's that
was a fact that was brought up several
times with dr anzlon
we're going to continue to do that work
and talk to the students in this focus
group setting to learn
from them what can we do to be more
accommodating within the federal
requirements and so we definitely want
to keep talking them and learning and
the other thing is i think that you know
the superintendent always makes us aware
of
national research and how this is
impacting the whole country
so three big factors to consider with a
strategy
um
relational network that's why we're
doing the focus groups the fam family
engagement piece
and then also
consistently taking a deep dive into the
trends that we're seeing so the reality
is this the trends that we've been
providing to you as a board in the last
few months it's a different trend free
pandemic so it's going to be important
that we continuously do this reflect on
the data that we're getting from the
focus groups and try to tackle that kind
of very tough dynamic thank you
sorry to send you a curveball i didn't
mean to
thank you trustee guzman i see that
trustee ford is in the queue
go ahead to see ford
thank you so much um okay so can you
just clarify for me really quick because
i've heard um some students speak about
how being
uh you know if you're late to one class
that that
you know 10 minutes later whatever that
that's an absence but then i just heard
that it's fifty percent of the day or
more can you just clarify
that exactly
go ahead dr mancy madam vice president
members of the board superintendent jara
trustee ford so the attendance codes are
applied per course um so
the situation that was explained earlier
that attendance code was applied to that
class that may have been missed the
overall calculation for chronic
absenteeism is 50 or more of the day in
totality
so if a student was absent or say tardy
um to a class every single day let's say
this
that was this parent's schedule actually
i've kind of been in this situation when
you have multiple kids and all their
starting times are like around the same
time let's say that they were late to
the first period every day
15 minutes
every day
what would it be like every three
tardies as an absent would it be
every day they're there
they have no absences or
what would that be
dr mancy madam vice president members of
the board superintendent jarrah trustee
ford for the purpose of the calculation
it looks at each day in isolation so 15
minutes would be applied to that
student's schedule as a absent time
versus the present time that would be
our six hour and 11 minute day so they
wouldn't be that's not a day of being
fully absent or 50 or more for that
student so it wouldn't accumulate like
you wouldn't compound the 15 minutes to
hit like half of a day and then that
would be the absence
of doctor
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent trustee ford for
the purpose of this calculation that's
not how the how it factors in for the 15
minutes it's kept just to that day
okay that's
thank you i i'm a little have some
questions
i'll bring up with you later because i
actually have two teenagers in school
and uh
i have
what this student was saying with my own
children so i think there might be maybe
some misunderstanding um
i've had to write notes to excuse
absences for a tardy that was 15 minutes
after drop-off time so um
if you're saying for the
actually looking at chronic absenteeism
that those ones would then be
not included
as far as the presentation
but it would be
counted for the student
dr mansi i believe that you've answered
the question uh several times but just
want to maybe there's another way to
describe it thank you go ahead madam
vice president member of the board
superintendent trustee ford
so
the situation with the tardies um
that's a code that was applied to the
course and the time that's missed for
the course so we have certain minutes
that are attributed to a class they
might be a 90-minute period there might
be a 45-minute period
depending on the time the student's able
to spend present in the course an
attendance code is applied if they were
absent fully for the period or if they
were tardy for the period we look at the
total minutes for the day to do the
purpose of the calculation here three
tardies there might be a policy at the
school site that does lead to other
pieces but that would be a tardy
accumulation not for the purpose of the
chronic absenteeism calculation
okay i'm i'm hearing the the response
and i've i'm understanding the response
it just seems like
it's not lining up with my personal
experience so
uh thank you i appreciate it um
so this was a big issue uh pre-covid uh
we were discussing this at length with
the clark county commission
uh i can specifically remember putting
my
back in it and i can see teachers lining
up with uh
solutions to this
the commissioners saying hey bring all
ideas to the table a lot of teachers
saying things like
hey give me some extra money and
i'll get these kids to school in the
morning you know i'll hunt them down and
they're not going to tell me no
so
i really would like to almost like get
back to that place
almost like this was already an issue
where are we compared to then
but that's going to be really difficult
without being able to
subtract the chronic absenteeism that is
due to covid whether sick quarantined or
directly because of the effects of covid
like taking on a second job and whatnot
so i guess i'm just interested to see
how can we get those numbers as close as
possible to what it might look like if
covid
wasn't a thing
have we considered maybe
surveying parents and families just to
say
or maybe surveying those that are
chronically absent and saying how many
of these days were covert related to get
to some closer answer
doctor i'm
making eye contact with me i believe
that's that's you dr barton
uh
go ahead thank you uh madam vice
president members of the board dr jarrah
trustee ford i i think it's it's a
complicated question again i'm not
trying to um not give a direct answer
here but i think
to gather that kind of information and
make a conclusion on what the covet
impact was would be difficult recall
that
pre-coveted we were making progress we
were we still had high chronic
absenteeism across the board and even in
particular student groups but there was
progress
to get to
the point of multiple agencies and that
you know you mentioned the county
we're continuing to double down on those
partnerships you know we again the
timeline dr anslon went over by june we
expect a report from our teapot
partnership with the county and what
that impact may have been
at the
macro and micro level because there's
definitely some interventions that they
do at particular schools and trying to
make an impact um but we we definitely
um have a lot of work to do but
concluding the impact from kovid i think
we struggle along with the other
districts we're talking to consistently
our comparative districts
we're just struggling to conclude
how dramatic that impact was and so um
our team will continue to again take a
deep dive into that data as we develop
trends and see trends
and bring it to the board um but that's
uh that's the best that we can do right
now trustee ford thank you it's it's a
tough task uh things i've read uh says
that we're not going to have that data
until covet is over probably two years
after it is completely over and we're
still in it uh last thing it was
mentioned briefly uh by dr angelone that
one of the things that keeps kids
showing up to school is the connecting
to one or more adults on campus
i think that that should be looked at
deeper i think that's something that
kind of got glazed over but might be a
fundamental reason why kids do or don't
show up
i recently spoke to the media and said
that it's my belief that before we focus
on recruiting new teachers and staff
that we should put major efforts
and resources into retaining our current
employees
who have already developed relationships
with students and who have
who have invaluable
insights into the unique needs in their
schools and the communities that they
serve
so i really feel like that might be a
missing piece and some of the things
that i've read nationally
mention that mentioned that sometimes or
not sometimes a lot of times the only
reason why a kid shows up to school
is because they know there's an adult
there who
cares so i'm good thank you thank you
chelsea ford i see trustee cabazos is in
the queue
go ahead uh thank you chessy garcia
morales um some of my questions have
been already been asked by my colleagues
but i think what we're talking about
here and you know thank you for all your
work on this and for bringing us these
updates uh they're very helpful along
with the briefings that we get on this i
can't remember i don't think i asked
this during this particular briefing but
some of the comments from
our constituents tonight it seems like
you know we're talking about life
happens you guys are looking at you know
really a global outlook here the bottom
line here cutting to the chase is that
we need our kids to be in school and so
you're looking at not only the symptoms
of the absenteeism but it looks like
you're taking a deeper dive into looking
at the root causes so my question here
would be
in looking at the comparisons that you
brought us and thank you for that to the
other districts was there any one thing
that you saw or that was different and
some like for instance washoe a little
bit higher some of the other ones i
think you said dr barton was at denver
and i can't remember the other one i'm
sorry
i'm sorry
miami-dade okay that were very similar
with our numbers was there anything that
you could put your finger on because i'm
hearing a lot of things from the public
commenters tonight that you know a lot
of it had to do with social emotional
learning some of the things that were
happening in their lives medical issues
um
i mean i'm just wondering if there was
any one particular challenge or
something that you saw that was
different
dr anselm
thank you vice president morales members
of the board dr jarrah um trustee
cavazos um great question
you're 100 accurate the emerging themes
continue to um show us that
students especially in some of the
larger urban districts like denver and
miami-dade
the students were being looked to for
more of that support within the family
as opposed to smaller districts or
even um you know less affluent districts
and so i think that's something that was
a common denominator that we found that
that that these students are being
needed by the family and and their
supports outside of the school much more
than others
thank you dr antoine so kind of
continuing with that just kind of
piggybacking on that
um
i like that you're not just uh looking
at you know just like truancy officers
as being the be all in the end all it's
just a moving piece and all the parts of
this so when we are looking at those
differences with other districts
um and again i'm gonna i'm gonna steal
trustee um because mods here uh raised
as far not wanting to throw you a
curveball here and a question that maybe
i didn't think of during the briefing
but would it be
probably to our benefit to find out if
possibly that some of these other
districts that are doing better with the
absenteeism rate did they start on
social emotional learning maybe a little
bit sooner than we did and you know i
know that our mtss system and looking at
the different tiers
are absolutely important and we have to
kind of take in stages i know many
conversations with dr barton but would
that be something that possibly in the
future that we could look at
dr bart
uh thank you uh
madam vice president members of the
board dr jarrah trustee cavazos
i think it's a fair question that we've
learned from our partnering districts
that there's definitely definitely a
difference in per pupil expenditure
there's a difference in definitely when
stages of sel was implemented or even a
mental health ecosystem to support
students
while we had efforts in the clark county
school district or even in the state of
nevada before the pandemic i think that
that created a magnifying glass to
create a sense of urgency where now
we're partnering with multiple
agencies care solace telehealth through
hazel health
to expand it on all campuses but i
definitely think to your point there's a
difference on when those supports were
provided
pandemic
okay um i think that you have answered
my question but i really i appreciate
that we are not just again i appreciate
your work all of you and uh your
briefings and that you are giving us
details on not just doing the band-aids
or the symptoms but looking at some of
the root causes that are underneath so i
thank you for that
i'm good
thank you trustee goodbusters to save dr
jara yeah matter of vice president
members of the board i think dr barton
is being modest
when you think about the work that
started
under dr barton's leadership around
mental health and the mtll teams in
every school the council of great city
schools has really highlighted that and
shared that across the country as the
leading effort
so there's a lot of things that we
continue to learn from i mean yesterday
i learned from some of the work that san
antonio is doing
up in new york city so there's a
constant learning curve that we're doing
with other districts
so just commend dr barton and his
leadership in the team because it's
something that has been highlighted and
shared with others
around some of this work not where we
need to be a lot of work ahead
i also like to point out i mean
community we've done an rfp for
community partners
um using sr dollars that's out there and
that's something that will continue so
if there's other community partners that
want to participate in helping our kids
um get to school
there's that possibility for the coming
year i know chicago public schools that
um they're doing a lot of work with uh
with the churches to really do those
knocking on doors um so that's that's
going to be continue to be out there and
available for community partners so it's
not just the ones that we currently have
but there's others
thank you dr jaram i see trustee brooks
has uh
questions
thank you i don't really have questions
um i do appreciate the information i
i want to be honest about where we are
as a district and the community i don't
expect us to reach these goals i think
it would be
i think it'd be unreasonable given the
fact that we're at the tail end
hopefully with the tail end of
a pandemic
attendance obviously has not been a
priority this year
people have struggled um entering
quarantine and going back to schools so
i want to be realistic that i
know that we are not going to meet these
goals and i am going to be okay with
that because i recognize that we have
prioritized health
and and that's been universally accepted
so i think we have a lot of work to do
but i also know that this isn't really
reflective of
a normal circumstance
so i think it's important to add that
nuance when you look at this information
and whether or not this is something
that we have
absolutely focused on and
prioritized and in my opinion
we haven't and i am okay with that given
the circumstances
thank you trustee brooks
trustee gabassos i'm going to take the
liberty to
share my comments and then i see you in
the queue thank you
my comments are simply thank you for
shining a light on this multifaceted
issue that exists in our school district
thank you for continuing to listen to
students and um
you know at the same time abiding by the
federal
definitions of chronic absenteeism that
we're
you know have to uphold
thank you for working with our
incredible partners the county the city
organizations who support this work
really my my comment is more also in
addition to to share my gratitude to you
and the team dr martin is
maybe
would like to encourage my colleagues to
i hear that there is continued concern
but
perhaps we would benefit from evaluating
in the near future
our legislative priorities and find ways
to
address
the concerns that our
staff have shared here this could be a
place where we could all collaborate
trustee cabazos
actually vice president garcia munoz i
think that my question is probably can
be better suited to 402 having to do
with safety and kind of making a
connection with the absenteeism and
school safety so i think i'm going to
hold off on that
thank you though very good
thank you so much at this time if there
are no other questions or comments we're
going to move on to 4.02
4.02
4.02
thank you gentlemen
so we're transitioning a little bit and
bringing some team members up
dr mancy are you solo running solo
all right man of the hour
4.02 moving on to 4.02 which is a
strategic plan update on student safety
dr mancy
vice president members of the board
superintendent jarrah
for the record greg manzi assistant
superintendent of assessment
accountability research and school
improvement division before you tonight
is a presentation aligned to the
district strategic plan focus 2024
providing an update on the indicator of
student safety
the indicator of student safety
contributes to the vision of the board
of school trustees through the student
success priority area specifically under
safety and engagement
the student safety results were
previously presented in march of 2015
october of 2016
and may of 2019.
the may of 2019 presentation included
results of the district-wide survey
overall that was presented during a
board work session
what you'll see here so the measure of
student safety included in focus 2024 is
derived from four questions within the
district-wide survey for students as
shown on the slide
it's important to note that the first
item responding negatively is actually
the desired outcome therefore responses
for this question are reversed to
calculate the measure of student safety
the district-wide survey for students is
administered on an annual basis
typically in the months of november and
december the most recent administration
took place from november 1st 2021 until
december 17th of 2021. the district-wide
survey for students is available in
english and spanish this is important as
the timing of the survey administration
and subsequent reports aligns to the
school performance framework
cycle as well as data review event at
the beginning of the second semester in
january and february
the current iteration of the survey is
in its sixth consecutive year and was
developed during the 2015-2016 school
year in partnership with west ed
the questions are from a combination of
prior ccsd iterations of the survey the
university of chicago consortium on
school research and the nevada
department of education
the full district-wide survey captures
student perceptions in a variety of
areas including parent involvement
learning attitudes social learning and
perceptions of school performance
the purpose of the district-wide survey
is to elicit feedback on the climate
culture and school community informing
our theory of action that if we focus on
strengthening school communities by
implementing multi-tiered system of
supports or mtss the student's
perception of safety will increase
the trustees may recall that during
december 9th 2021 regular board meeting
the board approved policy 6121
multi-tiered system of supports policy
61-21-20
requires that all schools in
collaboration with stakeholders
implement the district-wide framework
for multi-tiered system of supports to
ensure all students receive equitable
access to opportunities to promote each
student's academic achievement social
emotional growth and behavioral
development
the district-wide survey for students is
administered for students in grades 4
through grade 12. the district results
for the perception of safety are shown
on this first slide a consistent trend
that will be observed across all charts
shown today includes the increase in
perception of safety for the 2020-2021
results completed when the district was
implementing distance learning the 2021
2022 results reveal a return to rates
closely aligned to the percentages from
prior to the covet 19 pandemic with
slight increases observed across all
student groups when compared to the
2019-2020 results
on the next slide you'll find results
from the elementary schools for
elementary schools the results include
students in grade four and grade five
the grades at elementary are purposely
selected to allow for the highest degree
of independence and completion of the
survey therefore more reliable results
in the elementary school results we
observed that the increase during
distance learning was not as drastic but
surpassed 90 percent positive during
that time for the district and several
student groups
the results of the
2021-2022 school year reveal percentage
positive responses slightly higher
across the majority of student groups
when compared to the 2019-2020 results
on the third data slide you'll see the
results from middle schools for middle
schools the results include students in
grades 6 through grade 8.
in the middle school results we observe
a greater increase during the
2020-2021 school year while in distance
learning nearly approaching 90 positive
for middle school overall
all student groups also saw increases in
that same time frame
once again the results of the
2021-2022 school year reveal percentage
positive responses slightly higher
across most student groups when compared
to the 2019-2020
results
on the final data slide you will find
the results for high schools
for high schools the results include
students in grades 9 through grade 12.
in the high school results we observe a
greater increase during the 2020 2021
school year while in distance learning
across all student groups
and we see a return in school sites we
can observe that the results of the
2021-2022 school year are slightly
increased across all student groups when
compared to the 2019-2020 results
the district strategic plan outlines the
target percentage of students who feel
safe as measured by the district-wide
survey questions previously outlined the
table on this slide provides us with the
2021 2022 target and actual results
including an indicator that the targets
were not met
limited context is available to compare
the district performance to others it is
important to note that comparison rates
were generated based on similar
questions but no district asks identical
questions to ours
the results from los angeles unified
district were derived from one question
i feel safe in this school or in online
school sessions
when reviewing the annual trend for los
angeles unified district we do observe
that their results were likely
influenced similarly to ours during the
2020-2021 school year while in distance
learning
the results for washoe county school
district denver public schools and
miami-dade county public schools are
derived from a singular question all
similar to i feel safe at my school
results from albuquerque public schools
and houston independent school district
were not available for comparison
we acknowledge the challenges successes
and lessons learned as we reflect on the
results we recognize that we encountered
a challenge as students returned to
face-to-face learning reacclimating to
student school structures and systems
following a year of distance learning
within the results we also observed
success with an increase in survey
participation when compared to the
2020-2021 results
we also observed that the results
aligned to the pre-covet 19 results
across all grade bands with modest
improvement when compared to the 1920
school year
as part of a continuous improvement
process and reflection of the results we
developed lessons learned and a plan for
adjustments a lesson learned includes
recognizing that perceptions of safety
increased while in distance learning
our next steps are separated into two
slides the first slide is focused on our
next steps aligned specifically to the
district-wide survey the results of the
district-wide survey will be utilized by
continuous improvement teams as they
conduct the event called status check 8
as part of the school performance plan
process from may 2022 to june 2022
in the fall school continuous
improvement teams will have an
opportunity to revise the school
performance plan to incorporate action
steps that address the observations from
the district-wide survey results
the district-wide survey will open then
in november of 2022 and remain open
through december 2022 up until winter
break
the results of the survey administered
for the 22-23 school year will include
an analysis of additional indicators
such as panorama results and student
attendance
the second focus of next steps includes
actions to increase student safety
most recently we communicated the
emphasis of the clark county school
district pre-k through grade 12 student
code of conduct including apparent link
communication and video message provided
by the superintendent during the summer
region leadership will provide
district-wide multi-tiered system of
supports professional learning for
school site leaders that includes high
quality tier 1 academic and behavioral
instruction and supports
by august 2022 resources for school
sites will be provided including tier 1
safety protocols re-engagement
procedures and student communication
materials
thank you for your time
thank you dr mancy are we uh now are
taking questions from excuse me thank
you i want to jump straight into
questions but i'm grateful for trustee
guzman who reminds me of our public
comment
this time we have several members of the
audience who would like to speak on
public comment starting with adam tampa
anna binder sarah camro
and i'll announce a couple of others in
a minute
welcome back
autumn tampa speaking as an individual
first i want to note that i did the
survey
and
i did not think it was detailed enough
or specific enough or allowed for
enough comment
for people to give
more information it was very very
general and i don't you know so when you
think of safety i think of physical
safety
as somebody going to beat me up is
somebody going to shoot me when i go to
the parking lot
um is a student going to hurt me if i'm
on a high school campus
i've actually even been hurt by
elementary students when working so
there's physical then there's mental
are the people that i'm interacting with
playing any kind of
abuse games verbally are they you know
undermining my individuality are they
giving negative comments to me on a
daily basis i know i once observed a
second grade teacher calling her
children stupid on a regular daily basis
to me that was mental
unsafeness
then you have emotional unsafeness where
you know your emotions are not validated
where you're if you have a reaction that
you're not supposed to have then it's
you know your shame on you and that's
shaming and that's emotional unsafety
and i think all of those factors are
critically important and they're not
being looked at
um
i've been on many many campuses over 160
and i felt safe physically on most of
them i did not feel mentally or
emotionally safe on way too many of them
and i know that students
um and the whole culture of discipline
the whole culture of fold your arms and
march like a soldier and you better not
move or you better not turn the wrong
way don't look backwards it's absurd
they're children
they are supposed to be moving they're
supposed to be excited they're supposed
to have feelings so that whole
perspective needs to be fixed from top
down it's wrong and it's hurting people
thank you miss tampa is miss binder
still present
oh she'll uh in the meantime miss comro
would you like to come up
i think i hear her but
oh there she is forgive me
we'll go ahead miss binder
4.02
welcome back thank you thank you madam
president members of the board dr jarrah
um
so this uh
presentation
sorry i'll pull your page
waste my time i don't care sorry i could
have been more
prepared on that one 4.8.02
there we go so um focusing on students
safety we're still getting a lot of
reports from parents in the community
whose kids are being adversely
punished
for reporting
bullying and harassment and physical
contact that's being made to them on our
campuses
um
i'm sure
you guys hear a lot of that from your
community
hopefully in your respective districts
what was really really fascinating to me
because i saw that you guys referenced
um
going back to some surveys before covid
and when we were in shut down and i was
yelling about student suicide and things
like that and getting our schools back
open
um i took a look at a survey that
students complete once a year
and i thought it was really interesting
because i didn't really know about this
until i i found it and then i asked my
kids i'm like you guys really take this
every year and they're like oh
and uh
in that survey
they also these kids are also reporting
they don't have access to fresh fruits
and vegetables these students are like
over 40 50 60
at risk of contracting stds being
sexually assaulted becoming pregnant um
when we want to talk about safety
and we don't have you know them feeling
safe
and this kind of says that like oh we're
kind of getting back to like pre-code
that's a nightmare to even think about
so um
dr jarrah you mentioned you know for
people who want to help and all of this
stuff
i still have my nvla pta president who
hasn't been approved
thank you miss binder let's uh miss
comro are you available
and
then we have ed gonzalez and camilla by
waters
welcome back
thank you very much sarah camera for the
record and i think my last one for the
night
um
i i was looking at the data and
and it's very possible that i missed it
because i was trying to go through all
the papers
in that giant stack
but is this
survey
given
in students native language
for
bilingual and multilingual students and
for our
special education students and our
some of our low-level learners
um
is it read to them and i'm curious to
know what the wording in the questions
is because a lot of the surveys that i
have received as a as a teacher
ask me a question and then i start to
answer and i'm like wait
is it was it that or is it that i'm not
really sure it feels like i'm taking the
act and it's a trick question and i'm
like am i gonna get into the college i
want um
and these are supposed to be like very
simple straightforward questions but
they become complicated and so
it makes me
question the accuracy of the data
it also depends
uh does is the student in secondary ed
taking this survey
when they are um
in a class with a teacher they really
like
because in that moment
they feel safe
but maybe when they go to their next
period
kind of sketchy not so much and so i
just i question the validity of the data
if we don't know all of this back stuff
and maybe you guys know but i just feel
like that's stuff that you might want to
think about when you're looking at data
thank you so much
thank you miss conroe
ed gonzalez and then camilla bywaters
thank you ed welcome
come back
thank you madam vice president i
actually did leave so it is appropriate
to say welcome back
my name is ed gonzalez i will actually
put on a hat not just a physical one
community member hickey elementary
school organizational team um the reason
i'm commenting on this item is that
there was a review that was sent to the
school organizational teams about the
code of conduct
it was very vague it just asked to be
reviewed um our sot did actually take a
vote and um to ask the i believe this
would be under operationals for the
superintendent um one of the things
they're concerned i'll just read the
motion it's very
basic
um the motion was to send to the
district that the hickey elementary
school organization actually believed
that any attack on a staff member if
successful or not should be held to the
same standard and principals and
administrative teams should have more
say on student discipline
now i understand state law does not
necessarily allow for that it is ironic
that the legislature when i spoke
earlier in public comment
gave more authority and autonomy to
principles and at the same time when it
came to discipline they did the complete
opposite and made it go back into
central i understand the hypocrisy of
the legislature at times but the main
thing that our concern and i will give
you an example
let's say i'm a student and i throw a
chair at a teacher the difference in
punishment this code of conduct is
whether that that chair hits the teacher
and injures them so if the teacher is
swift enough to move out of the way it's
a different level punishment now i
understand that it should be treated
slightly different but it should be held
at the same standard because the intent
was there i'll give you in a sports
analogy if you attack an official it's
the integrity of the game and you
usually are banned for life i'm not
suggesting that under this policy but
i'm suggesting it should be held in the
same area level and within it there
should be some you know varying levels
depending where it is that is what the
hickey elementary school organization
team believes because we are concerned
that staff members are being attacked
staff members are getting hit and what's
the appropriate punishment my chair has
come here before and saying that all
behavior is learned and if they feel
like they can throw a chair and get away
with it what's the next student going to
do thank you madam vice president
thank you mr gonzalez spy waters
camila bywaters president of the las
vegas alliance of black school educators
i definitely agree with the sentiments
that were made about the validity and
the reliability of the survey
i think it would be also important to
maybe tweak this a little bit
and see
look at the results but also to include
um
an opportunity for students to
state
why
they feel unsafe and what specifically
makes them feel unsafe
in schools um that that will really be
the only way that we can target
solutions when we understand the
specific reasons
um one of the big issues that also
impacts student safety is the lack of
appropriate
and effective
response
when issues are brought to school
leaders there has to be an immediate
response to these issues for example i
just sent each of you a letter
about desert oasis high school
two parents had complaints about some
issues there went to the school and they
did not feel that their um issues were
addressed and in fact their daughter two
daughters
were expelled and the individuals who
were causing these situations were not
treated the same way
um so it really is important that
um student safety
issues from families are addressed in a
timely fashion
so that students don't take these
matters into their own hands and also
parents
so parents don't take these matters into
their own hands um the parent actually
said to me
i wish i would have not gone to the
school and handled the situation myself
but he thought that coming to the school
he'd be able to get some solutions and
nothing happened and i could see that
this is a problem that's happening
throughout our district that issues are
not being handled um
consistently and in a timely fashion
thank you miss bywaters at this time i
don't see any more public comments
however um
now we can move on to trustee questions
trustee williams i see you in the queue
go ahead
thank you madam vice president um
dr mandy i was
i guess i only have like a question and
a comment but do you when you get these
survey results do you
go over this or review them with the
ccsdpd
go ahead dr mancini madam vice president
members of the board superintendent jara
trustee williams
the results specifically are not
reviewed with ccsdpd we don't hold a
session or anything with them for that
availability can i ask why dr jarrah
dr jarrow
forgive me
banner vice president members of the
board um we do not but we do review them
in cabinet and chief black guy sits in
my cabinet so when we review that we
um as a team review so we can get to
address some of the issues and kind of
get into the next steps and chief black
guy sits in my cabin at me okay thank
you dr jar and then i guess my only
comment is on your slide
um
slide five
i understand this is the part of the
mtss system that i think dr
larson mitchell had had briefed to us
i want to say it was last summer maybe
i'm not quite sure
but on the very end of that it says
increased perception of safety
and while i understand there's a
perception of safety and actuality of
safety i
i get worried or worrisome about the the
concept of like are we
working on actually making the school
safe as opposed to
letting that letting other people
perceive that they're safe and so that's
just my only comment to it i think
sometimes that word it gets thrown
around and people are like oh it must be
safe because it's perceived to be safe
um and then with every student having a
cell phone and every single time
something goes off it ends up on twitter
or instagram whatever that's it
decreases the perception like that would
be my only comment but thank you so much
for this
thank you trustee williams i see trustee
guzman is in the cube go ahead
thank you madam vice president um
mr manzi there are a couple of things
that i
have questions about first
do you define safety for the students in
the
survey
dr mancy
mountain vice president members of the
board superintendent jarrah trustee
guzman there is no definition provided
it's about this the student's perception
of that word and that information as
they answer the question so we're not
telling them what safety looks like
they're just answering based on what
they know as safety
madam vice president members of the
board yes okay okay i just want to make
sure and then you did mention
uh dr manzi in your when you were
showing us the slides that um the survey
was um in english and in spanish is that
correct
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent jara trusty guzman
yes that's correct
spanish and english are the languages
for the survey great and um
is the is the survey read to our special
ed kids
madam president members of the board
superintendent jara so when students
have those reasonable accommodations
that are written in and they need that
support that would be provided for them
by their teacher okay so if it's
included in their iep then then they
would have it read to them correct okay
great
and then um
my last question has to be uh is about
the time of year that we choose to
do this particular survey is there a
reason why we choose november to
december to do this type of survey
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent jara trustee guzman
so the time of year is really critical
for the survey it gives us the students
some time in their building to get their
perceptions and understanding as well as
align to the school performance process
and being able to generate the results
and use it within the school year to
implement change for the second semester
thank you i appreciate that
thank you chelsea guzman i see
josie gabassos
in the queue and i will turn your mic on
thank you thank you uh vice president
garcia morales i just have uh one uh
question um
dr mancy and this is kind of this is
when i asked at the briefing but of
course the public doesn't see your
briefings and also too one of our
constituents brought it up tonight too
and this has to do with um you know when
they answer the questions you gave us
the exact questions i believe that how
it's worded so that's the literal
language that was used correct
so i had asked during the briefing but
there isn't any place where you know
that they can put an additional comment
you know i do not feel safe
what is the reason you don't feel safe
you know this is a survey format correct
is there uh anything that we're looking
at and again at appropriate grade level
you know like the elementary middle and
high school is there anything we're
looking at where possibly that that
could be incorporated into that even if
it was just very brief
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent jara trustee
cavazos so we have other tools that
provide those
that avenue for a student safevoice
being one of them where they can type in
that information um provide that comment
which alerts appropriate staff to be
able to take action at the school site
then
thank you dr mancy so we have those
other which i'm well aware of and which
i'm very happy that we do have
but what i'm saying is that there isn't
any connection between that survey and
the results of that survey
it's not really like there's not like a
follow-up or connection to then these
other
entities
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent jarrah trustee
cavazos they the survey serves the
purpose of being able to capture climate
and
community and perception um that is the
intent of the survey not to do those
additional connections to them provide
intervention to a specific student okay
so then the other entities would be used
for the specific interventions and this
is just
more kind of a global look at how
they're feeling there isn't you know
basically they're checking it off and
there isn't a place for them putting
comments thank you so much i appreciate
it
thank you jose capuscals trustee ford
thank you um
can you explain a little bit the
questions
and for instance um
we i'm sorry i think i lost my
thingy okay
so we asked four
questions i'm just kind of repeating
what we said four questions on the
survey one of them being
reversed
the four are i sometimes stay home
because i don't feel safe at school
students feel safe in this school
this school has safety procedures that
work and this school is safe
um so that's what we've been doing and
we've been doing it for
what like five or six years something
like that
six years um
and then and we're comparing
our responses of our survey to
all the other districts in that chart
which is great um
but how different are their questions
than our
questions madam vice president members
of the board superintendent jarrah
trustee ford um
for the other districts that are there
we found that most of their questions
were a singular question
i feel safe at school being a common one
that was what we used to report the
comparison information
ours is the four questions that we've
outlined to kind of encapsulate the
student safety climate overall
okay so here's my comments which you've
already heard on my briefing
for the record that
of all these four questions
none of them actually ask
if that individual student feels safe at
school
in fact they could be interpreted um
like students feel safe in school you
know maybe i'm a student at the school
and i don't feel safe for whatever
personal reason and i'm thinking
no one else feels this way like
obviously i'm only the only one that
feels unsafe in this way i look around
and all my all the other students
appear to feel safe i might
check the box of
yeah students do feel safe in this
school
as far as the school has safety
procedures that work
um
like it was asked earlier
could it be interpreted like
maybe that student's not considering
things like that they actually fear
whatever that is but maybe they're
looking around and going oh it looks
like there's an
operable check-in system and nobody can
really get through the front door
without you know strangers can't get in
but they're not considering
other safety procedures
um so i guess i'm just trying to say
that i feel like if we're going to
compare to other districts
that we have to be comparing the
content of that metric and in the same
similar way
if we'd change it it would
skew some of our data
and it would you know we'd be off a
little bit in the six years but it might
be worth looking at it
can you um
can you clarify
one more time
let's say i'm a student
i take these this four questions survey
how many of these do i have to mark
positive for it to be considered a
positive result
madam vice president members of the
board superintendent jara trustee ford
um it's an aggregate measure so if the
student only answers three of the four
questions we would use the results from
the three questions to come up with the
total percent positive that's presented
before you here today so we do look at
each individual question but come up
with an aggregate number and that's what
you're seeing in the report
okay so if i was a student and i
you know say that i don't stay home
because of my safety fears
and i and i say that the students most
of the students feel safe and i say
the check-in system is working
and whatnot even those three things that
would be a pretty high result
for for me but nobody asked me if i
actually
personally feel safe
that's just one of the things i think we
should consider um
because i do have i brought it up at my
briefing but i do have questions about
the validity of the data
and while
i would like to see improvement in
climate and culture and so
i almost want to see
results that reflect what we're hearing
and what we're seeing
from students so that we could really
know if the changes that we're
implementing right now and we're
implementing a lot of really positive
changes
are actually making a dent in how our
students feel
regarding their safety at school so i
think it's a question worth
looking at
and i'm okay for now thank you
trustee brooks
do you have any questions or comments at
this time
thank you vice president garcia morales
i
have just been listening to the comments
there is a really good tool that other
board members can go check out some
comparison data around the state
um it's at datatool.nevada
it actually will let you look up this by
school it'll let you look up
and compare it by
the states
and
other districts so i would encourage
us to
start looking at data like that um i
think the purpose of
this information being collected in this
manner is so that we can compare it and
if we start
talking about um
and critiquing the questions and instead
of focusing on what it means what we're
gonna do about it and how we're gonna
use it to actually inform our decisions
i think sometimes to get a little bit
sidetracked
so i would encourage everybody to
look this information up because i think
it's really important to have that
mindset
i appreciate the information i know that
this year has been rough and i don't
have any questions i know that we have a
lot of work to do
in regards to this especially given the
climate and culture
just in general and i am committed to
doing it with staff
so thank you
thank you trustee brooks i hear the
comments of my colleagues that this
continues to be a item they want to
continue to learn more about and
grateful that this has come before the
board today thank you dr mancy for your
time
i'm gonna go ahead and move on to item
5.01 trustee and superintendent business
2021 2022 nrs statues their 388 a
2 33 5 year charter school site
evaluation report and presentation
this is a presentation discussion and
possible action regarding the 21 22 nrs
statues 388a
0.223
five-year charter school site evaluation
report to submit to the director of the
legislative council bureau for
transmittal to the legislative committee
on education as required by assembly
bill 462 of the 80th session of the
nevada legislature
at this time
hello hi hello
i think we're
grateful to have you here before us
please go ahead
madam president esteem board members
superintendent jarrah deputy
superintendent larson mitchell for the
record dan tafoya office of school
choice
thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to present this evening
i will now refer you to the slides on
the screen
during the 80th legislative session the
legislature revised statute 388 223
which requires the sponsor of a charter
school to conduct site evaluations for
each campus of a charter school that
sponsors during the first third and
fifth years after entering or renewing a
charter contract
all of our six sponsored charter schools
are currently in their fifth year of a
six-year contract
the ccsd office of school choice has
conducted site evaluations on an annual
basis for over the past 10 years which
includes a thorough examination of the
academic financial and operational
components as per the agreed upon
charter contract
the statute requires three components to
be examined first evaluation of pupil
achievement and student performance at
each campus our office evaluates schools
by using metrics and measures which are
based upon the board approved charter
school sponsorship guide the nevada
performance framework nevada revised
statute and regulations and other
documents
second
identify any deficiencies relating to
pupil achievement and school performance
identification of deficiencies regarding
the areas of academic financial and
operational performance are discovered
through annual site evaluations and
audits
site evaluations are conducted with
respect to school autonomy and agree
upon agreed upon charter contract third
plans to correct such deficiencies
additionally charter schools have
various support teams
charter schools have various support
teams from
and with uh in collaboration with ccsd
in an effort to correct any areas of
deficiencies that are discovered with a
common goal of improving student
achievement and overall student
performance
i will now briefly update update the
board on each school
first the 100 academy the 100 academy
school of engineering and technology was
found to have deficiencies in the
academic financial and organizational
components further agreed upon ccsd
charter school performance framework
during the 2017 2018 2018 2019 2019 2020
and the 2021 school years
as for academic performance
due to the school's academic performance
during the 2017-2018 school year the
board of school trustees voted in 2019
to reconstitute the governing body of
the 100 academy per nrs 388 a 330. the
reconstitution stipulated that the
school would improve its academic
performance during the remainder of the
charter contract
in 2018-2019
the school did improve its elementary
performance from one star to a two-star
rating on the nevada school performance
framework the middle school program
remained a two-star school but had
improved in the area of growth on the
nspf in both mathematics
and english language arts
this effort improved the nspf score by
5.8 points
in accordance with the us department of
education elementary and secondary
education act esea the esea waiver nde
suspended the accountability
requirements for the 2019 2020 and the
2020 2021 school years in response to
the covet pandemic the nspf school
ratings and accountability indicators
were carried over from the 2018-2019
reporting year therefore the school has
not had the opportunity to provide
academic performance results regarding
regarding the 2021 and 2022 school year
nde has not released the final nspf
measurements when nde reinstates nspf
accountability measurements the school
will evaluate the academic performance
of the school
and this goes for all the schools we're
going to discuss tonight they were all
exempt from the nspf
during those time periods i discussed
the financial performance at 100 academy
the 100 academy was found to have
deficiencies in the finance financial
performance each year of the current
charter contract the school was issued a
notice of concern or a notice of breach
per the charter school sponsorship guide
and charter contract each of the
deficiencies have been addressed by the
charter school
organizational 100 academy was found to
have deficiencies in the organizational
performance each year of the charter
contract the school was issued a notice
of concern or notice of breach per the
charter school sponsorship guide and
charter contract each of the
deficiencies have been addressed by the
charter schools
by the charter school thank you
slide four
the delta academy the delta academy was
found to have deficiencies in the
academic financial and organizational
components perth agreed upon contract
and charter school performance framework
during the 2017 2018 2018 2019 2019 and
2020 and the 20 20 21 school years
academic performance due to the school's
academic performance during the
2017-2018 school year the board of
school trustees voted in 2019 to
reconstitute the delta academy governing
body per nrs 388 a 330. the
reconstitution stipulated the school
would improve its academic performance
during the remainder of the charter
contract in 2018-2019 the school did
improve its middle school performance
from a one tar one star to a two-star
rating on the nspf in 2020 the high
school applied for and was granted
placement on the nevada department of
education's alternative performance
framework again nde carried the previous
nspf scores over to the co over due to
the covet 19 pandemic when nde
reinstates the nspf and apf
accountability measures the school
will be evaluated for their academic
performance based on those measures
financial performance the delta academy
was found to have deficiencies in their
financial performance in the 2019-2020
and the 2021 school years the school was
issued a notice of concern and a notice
of breach per the charter school
sponsorship guide and the charter
contract the delta
the delta academy governing body has
submitted a corrective action plan and
continues to address financial
deficiencies
organizational performance the delta
academy was found to have deficiencies
in organizational performance for the
2019 2020 and the 2020-21 school years
the school was issued a notice of
concern and a notice of breach per the
charter school sponsorship guide and the
charter contract the delta academy
governing body has submitted a
corrective action plan and continues to
address these deficiencies
next slide is explore knowledge academy
the explorer knowledge academy was found
to have deficiencies in the academic
component further agreed upon ccsd
charter school performance framework
during the 2017 and 2018 school year due
to the school's academic performance in
the middle school during the 2017 and
2018 school year the explorer knowledge
academy was issued a notice concern for
the charter school sponsorship guide and
the charter contract in the 2018-2019
school year the school did improve its
academic performance in the middle
school from a two-star to a three-star
rating on the nspf
again
their scores were carried over due to
the coveted pandemic
financial performance for all years of
the charter contract there were no
financial deficiencies to report
organizational for all years of the
current charter contract
explorer knowledge had no organizational
deficiencies to report
innovations international charter school
of nevada innovations international
charter school was found to have
deficiencies in the academic financial
and organizational components for the
agreed upon ccsd charter school
performance framework during the
2017-2018 2018 2019 2019 and 2020 and
the 20 20 21 school years academic
performance due to the school's academic
performance in 2017-2018
school year the innovations
international charter school in nevada
was issued a notice of concern per the
charter school sponsorship guide and
charter contract in the 2018-2019 school
year the school did improve its academic
performance from a two-star to a
three-star
on the nspf at all grade levels k
through 12.
or should say testable grade levels
financial performance international
innovations international charter school
of nevada was found to have deficiencies
in their financial performance each year
the current charter contract the school
was issued a notice of concern or a
notice of breach per the charter school
sponsorship guide and the charter school
contract each of the deficiencies have
been addressed by the charter school
organizational performance innovations
international charter school is found to
have deficiencies in their
organizational performance for the
2019-2020
2020-2021 school years the school was
issued a notice of concern and a notice
of breach per the charter school
sponsorship guide and the charter school
contract each of the deficiencies have
has been sufficiently addressed by the
charter school
odyssey charter school odyssey charter
school was found to have deficiencies in
the academic component per the agreed
upon ccsd charter school performance
framework during the 2017-2018 school
year due to the school's academic
performance at the elementary and high
school during the 2017-2018 school year
odyssey charter school was issued a
notice of concern per the charter school
sponsorship guide in the charter
contract in the 2018-2019 school year
the school did improve its academic
performance from a two-star to a
four-star rating in the elementary
school and from a two-star to a
three-star rating in the high school on
the nevada nspf again their scores were
carried over due to the coveted pandemic
financial performance for all years of
the charter contract there were no
financial deficiencies to report
organizational performance for all years
of the charter contract there were no
organizational deficiencies to report as
well
the rainbow dreams early learning
academy was found to have deficiencies
in the academic financial and
organizational components per the agreed
upon ccsd charter school performance
framework during the 2017-2018 2018-2019
2019-2020 and the 20-20-21 school years
due to the school's academic performance
during the 2017-2018 school year the
board of trustees in 2019 placed the
school on a mandated remediation plan
the plan stipulated that they would
improve their academic performance
during the remainder of the charter
contract in 2020 rainbow dreams early
learning academy requested to eliminate
services to grade uh to grades one
through eight and to change the mission
of the rainbow dreams
early learning academy charter school to
only serve pre-kindergarten and
kindergarten students
on their campus on june 11 2020 the ccsd
board of trustees approved the request
for the school to serve pre-k and
kindergarten only the school
will use um and has used industry
standard evaluation tools such as
brigance and my standards golds to
measure students growth and achievement
since they are no longer being rated on
the nspf
as for financial performance for the for
the
2017-2018 through the 2019-2020 school
year all financial performance
deficiencies have been addressed
as for the 2021 school year rainbow
dreams early learning academy was issued
a notice of breach by ccsd the notice of
breach identified a financial deficiency
which was based upon the school owing an
outstanding debt to the nevada
department of education at the time this
report was published rainbow dreams
early learning academy had not
sufficiently addressed the performance
deficiency i am pleased to report to
this board this evening that the school
has paid its debt in full
to the nevada department of education
and and has sufficiently addressed the
financial deficiency to the satisfaction
of the sponsor
all financial performance deficiencies
as of now have been addressed
organizational performance rainbow
dreams early learning academy was found
to have
deficiencies in their organizational
performance for the 2019-2020 and the
20-20-21 school year the school was
issued a notice of concern per the
charter school sponsorship guide and the
charter contract each of the
deficiencies have been addressed
sufficiently by the school
same board superintendents
that concludes my report thank you mr
tafoya for your presentation
at this time i'd like to take public
comments
5.01
we have
miss camilla bywaters 5.01
and
a miss binder
i didn't mean to wink at you that way
just just though we've got you we've got
you miss binder
welcome back hey camila bywater is
president of the las vegas alliance of
black school educators so i think um
principal henry deserves a handclap here
for that increase of
standards that's not easy to do
after four years of having to bring a
school to a new standard one thing i
would like to address though
rainbow dreams
is
a black-owned school
and
i could not
after i learned about
the kind of pressing and
bill collecting that was going on
um it seemed that there was not really
any grace in the matter
and um in collecting and turning in the
fees to whoever these fees need to be
turned into so i'm glad to know that it
was stated today that the school is
debt-free and has paid back what they
have owed
um but it is one it is kind of
concerning to me that there was such a
pressing
and
close to
stressful
for
a school in
89106 to be given such a pressure
to
pay their bill which
there was never a problem with paying
the bill
so i would
i think it's really important that we do
what we can to support our schools that
support our minoritized communities
especially early early learning schools
there's not too many opportunities for
our black and brown babies to attend
schools that provide such a great great
service so i do think that it's very
commendable that miss henry has been
able to get a staff that is phenomenal
at rainbow dreams my daughter attends
rainbow dreams she knows her abc she
knows how to write her name and she
knows how to come to the school board
meeting and cut up a little bit so
i do just want to make sure that there's
a recognition
of
the work that she has done to
have a good report here
thank you miss bywaters miss binder
thank you um so i actually was
going to hit that um because
at the state level there's many many
conversations going on in the early
learning
category and trying to increase services
to our
communities because early education is
one of the most amazing things that we
can give our children so um but miss
bywaters was here tonight so
she kind of hit the rest on the head but
there's great strides at the state level
being made for the investments into more
support in our community
for early education and i believe
they're getting ready to do a roundtable
i think in the next quarter to bring
people in the community in for better
ideas in
zip codes that are typically left out of
those conversations so
thank you miss pender dr jara
yeah madam president members of the
modern vice president members of the
board i just need to correct a record
because this staff has
intimately worked
with congressman horsford
with the state department to address the
needs and the county commissioner
kirkpatrick
worked with us
to provide the support for her rainbow
dreams and really working closely as we
went through the payment plans i just
needed to correct a record in our grace
in supporting the community
congressman horford has been in close
contact with dr barton and myself
to make sure that children are served
this community thank you
thank you for your support dr jarrah
at this time i'd like to turn it over to
my colleagues
because we're
ready for questions and i don't see
anybody in the queue right now
perhaps
trustee brooks
leslie brooks doesn't have any questions
i would like to put myself in the queue
i don't have any questions thank you
thank you trustee brooks my question
uh dr uh mr tafoya could you
provide us provide us insight on how we
came into overseeing charter schools
steam trustees superintendent and staff
uh thank you for that question
in the 1990
1999 legislature there was a
bill passed that allowed
people such as or entities such as
school districts and uh the state to
sponsor charter schools so it was a law
that was enacted and a matter of fact we
have one of the oldest charter schools
that was a part of that law that's
odyssey charter school that's been
around now 22 years so it was enacted
through that law and the school district
at that time
started open charter schools the state
did as well
and at this time we have a state charter
authority that oversees
specific charter schools i mean there
always has been some authority right at
the state level
so uh
i just want to verify and confirm that
that's the case is that right
trustee superintendent and staff for the
record dan tafoya uh that is correct at
one time it was the nevada department of
education uh through a legislative act
there was the formation of the charter
school authority which does see oversee
other charter school portfolios
throughout the state
washoe county school district also sees
a portfolio of schools such as clark
county and carson city i believe sees
one of those schools as well thank you
mr tafoya dr jarrow yes madam vice
president members of the board there's
also a provision within the charter law
if at any time and mr tafoya can speak
to that
where
the school board can then transfer
back charter schools into current
charter schools that we authorize and
supervise and transfer them to the state
charter authority as well so there is
there is a provision within the statute
to do that for that to happen as well dr
does that happen
mr tafoya does that happen at any time
or is that a
um
can that happen anytime or does it have
to happen a specific time of the year no
i mean i think it's it's a conversation
that we would have to have with the
state charter authority obviously the
main and priority is to make sure that
when that happens it's aligned to a
school year and to make sure that the
children are served
so i think it's it's if it's something
that there's an interest that we can
start having conversations with the
state charter authority to do that
thank you dr jar i my
uh
the reason i asked about the history and
and the insight is because as i'm seeing
i'm grateful for the progress that's
taken place in
some of the charter schools that we
really have that have been presented
here today
and hearing some of the challenges and
hardships that some
real challenges and hardships that some
of our students face and oftentimes in
the neediest community
i wonder whether we are the right
unit to be supporting
um
our charter schools i mean it's a really
hard conversation to have because um you
know we have been supporting them and it
sounds like we're on a five-year
agreement five-year agreement is that
what i heard six-year agreement five
year of a six-year
but it i
i would like to have that discussion at
some point and that
you know this presentation is a glaring
reminder that we
we should have it
dr jarrah
modern vice president members of the
board
we can start having the internal
conversations with staff to start
looking at it and to see what the
potential obviously for us
and for the state charter authority and
and for you as well as making sure that
we take care of our children
and what that looks like
so we can then look at it and see what
the timelines and then we can bring
something
back to this board
thank you dr jarrah i'm gonna
go back uh
i appreciate those questions those
answers i'm gonna i see that trustee
ford has a question or like to be in the
queue go ahead trustee ford
thank you so much um couple questions um
first you know there's all different
types of charters charter schools
including online schools that would
run much differently than
traditional brick and mortar schools are
all of the
charter schools that we are sponsoring
are they all traditional style
students in the seat type of schools or
are there any type of
alternate versions of education
for the record uh steam board
superintendent and staff uh dan tay for
the record uh we do have odyssey charter
school which is a hybrid school uh where
children in turn uh
attend online part of the week and
they're in person uh part-time we also
have delta academy which is a school
that is as i mentioned earlier under the
apf they do have students that attend
online and
full-time and some students who in who
attend in between as well other schools
are traditional schools that uh are
brick and mortar face-to-face type
schools
thank you um
so the purpose of this was really to
compare
you know using the same standards how
successful a charter school would be
as a public school i guess i'm just
trying to knowing that two of them
look different than most of our schools
i guess except for
um oh my god i can't think of it
learning academy
um
how similar are these schools to ccsd
like are we seeing
is it comparable classroom sizes
is it um are we seeing
the same rates of absenteeism do they
like do we have any of that information
for the record is steam board
superintendent and staff um
dan tafoy for the record so
the charter schools are mandated under
many of the same nde regulations as um
regular school districts would be
so a lot of the class sizes are
comparable absenteeism rates are
pretty much uh as you would see in the
district some schools you see they have
a comparative absenteeism rate other
schools you see that maybe uh it is a
higher absenteeism rate than this than
the school it's surrounded by
and in some cases you see the
absenteeism
absenteeism rate lower than the local
public school that
the student may attend
thank you um so i guess i'm trying to
figure out
so for public ccsd schools
we have
you know it doesn't matter how many kids
there are versus how many teachers or
space there is we're going to take all
students and all
behavior levels and all
needs of different students so
i guess
knowing that some of our schools might
be short on staff and several classes
combined into large areas like the
cafeteria and the gym and things
uh dealing with some things that arise
from their like violence and whatnot
is that something that
they do as well
or is there some sort of cap on class
sizes or attendance
or is it just
i guess how different is that in our
schools
trustee ford for the record um dan
tafoya
there are a lot of similarities uh you
know after the pandemic a lot of our
schools have faced exactly the same
issues that we've faced as well
i can't point to specifics as to exact
comparison or data studies
but i think that there's been a shortage
of employees there's been a
shortage of the ability
for parents to send their their kids to
school i think they face many of the
same issues that we face as well
there are caps such as there are
mandated by nd for the state uh for the
uh clark county school district there
are the similar caps for them and so
what we have to do is monitor that to
see where they are um
it is um
it is very comparable to what you are
are describing i think all schools not
only in nevada but nationwide are
affected by many of the same problems
thank you um
do
is transportation provided to these
schools
trustee board board superintendent staff
for the record uh schools do have the
ability to provide transportation none
of the sponsored charter schools in our
portfolio do i'm not aware of any in the
state at this point uh that do that's a
very expensive endeavor they can
they can
partner with this school district to be
able to
do that type of partnership where there
could be some transportation but of
course it would come at a cost and
charter schools with their budget uh
typically does they don't have the
ability to provide transportation the
other thing is they pull from multiple
zip codes so it would be a big
undertaking for them to be able to have
charter schools uh
provide transportation i think it would
it be fair to say that to attend one of
these charter schools that would
the parents would pretty much have to be
able to handle transportation to and
from school trustee ford seemed bored
superintendent staff for the record dan
tafoya uh
it it would be a very fair statement
that uh
parents do have to provide that
transportation for their students and
they have done so since i've been here
thank you um i i want all schools to
succeed i you know i
obviously if kids are happy at their
schools we hope that they can meet the
standards i just want to of course
always
look at the data in a way that if we're
comparing against each other that it is
fair and accurate
i would i would just hate to like
compare on unfair metrics and then make
the claim that
charters are more effective
than ccsd schools and then you know lose
funding to more charters
while at the same time i do want to
support
you know different options of schools
and
innovation and you know responses to the
communities desired schools and whatnot
um
but my question my last question is
well first i think it's great that uh
the ones that we've been overseeing have
made the successes that they have and i
really like the change of rainbow dreams
i think it's awesome but
now that we're in the fifth of the sixth
year
what happens next if uh for say
a couple of them are not meeting the
standards in the future what would the
next step be
trustee ford
uh the steam board
superintendent and staff for the record
dan tafoya uh so as we start to approach
the end of the contract uh we would look
at the data that we have
we have the data that you see in front
of us and
where you see that
it may say falls below the standard or
doesn't meet the standard is because at
the time of audit the school may have
had
a deficiency they might have had a
write-up they may have been missing
something in a special education folder
these are very stringent type audits so
it only takes one thing for you to not
meet a standard and audit you can come
back and correct that and bring it back
into alignment but we're not going to
change the rating it was the way it was
when we found it and we do that for
transparency's sake so
it would be very easy to say well i
fixed it let's turn it into green and
then all i would show you is green but
the truth of the matter through the um
through the process of uh audit and
transparency when we in
when we inspect those schools uh what we
find is what we report we do give them
the opportunity for the nrs to make
those corrections and if they make those
corrections then they are allowed to
continue to operate
if a school was not to make one of those
corrections then we would come back to
this board we would issue the proper
legal documents to the school if they
still refuse we would come up we would
bring them back to the board for the
board to consider uh either a sanction
or or a revocation of that charter
um
so
in the fact that you may see that
there's red and there's yellow it means
at that time that did not meet the
standard but
we bring them back to the board um
if they did not if they chose not to
make that standard for some reason say
they went bankrupt then you would we'd
be in front of you with a bankruptcy
issue okay very interesting question
thank you so much
trustee williams
thank you madam vice president mr tafoya
thank you for your comprehensive report
i
tried to take a lot of that in right as
you're saying but you should speak very
fast um so i just want to say thank you
and then my only question is with
rainbow dreams last year being their
first year doing pre-k and
again only right
um so then that that report it will be
five more years or is that where you
guys are just basing your data off of
just the one or year or two year every
year you guys are just re-looking at
that
trustee williams
the steam board superintendent staff for
the record dan tafoya so
annually we monitor we have different
departments that monitor
the progress that they make
uh in those areas and we compare we make
those comparison data
this is their first year so we don't
have any comparison data yet
but we will bring that back to the board
the next time that we do have that data
so they can see where the students have
moved from point a to point b
and see if that is sufficient in those
lower grade levels
pre-k and k
there are measurements out there that i
think that statistically could be
significant uh as far as monitoring and
providing um
a description of how the school is
performing wonderful thank you so much i
am very big fan of charter schools and
uh
secondary education schools for students
in our district so i think that's great
um i don't know if i need to make a
motion but i'd like to make a motion
just to accept the report and
move on to our next item but thank you
so much mr tafoya
thank you for that motion trustee
williams do we have a second
see trustee guzman in the queue
i'll second
thank you we have a motion for trustee
williams and a second by trustee guzman
trustees please cast your vote
trustee brooks
hi
emotion passes six to one noting trustee
um
absent
six to zero why do i keep saying one
she's here in spirit
i miss you
president zepeda
all right um thank you very much mr
tafoya for your time
i think we are ready
to move on to 5.02
opening of sealed bids
call for oral bids and resolution of
acceptance of bids offered to sell real
property site number zero
64.02 dash 2.4 that is uh 2.5 acres of
the southeast corner of rancho destino
road and east
prieras avenue fresh avenue discussion
and possible action on the opening of
seal bids calling for
oral bids accepting the highest bid and
adapting
adopting a resolution declaring the
highest bid to sell
to sell a 2.5 acre parcel located on the
southeast corner of rancho casino road
and east i just repeated that same thing
assessors parcel 1772-28-401-006
and for the superintendent of clark
county school districts and the
president and the clerk of the board of
trustees county school district to sign
the resolution of acceptance bid is
recommended i see the contact person is
mr campbell
and um
forgive me
um trustees did we um seek
public comment first before
the last time we did this public comment
first before we open the seal bids i
don't think so no okay
uh there is isn't there a
no
no
no
okay nope just kidding i want to be
proactive thank you
uh
guzman i appreciate
you're ready with the envelope
all right
ready ready
okay i need to read these instructions
uh stick with mine would you mind
opening the envelope please
thank you
[Music]
we're going to open the bid and read out
loud each bit amount and the same and
the name of the submitter
go ahead go ahead trustee guzman i'm
going to turn on your mic so we can
maybe tag team this are you willing to
do that yeah sure
okay thank you
um it says the undersigned saint charbel
maronite catholic mission las vegas real
estate trust having carefully examined
the resolution of intent to sell real
estate property and notice inviting bids
adopted by the board of school trustees
of the clark county school district on
april 7
2022 hereby submits a bid in the total
amount of five hundred and thirty
thousand dollars
for
the southeast corner of rancho destino
road and east frias avenue las vegas
nevada 89183
assessor parcel number
177-28-401-006 for a total of 2.5 acres
the northwest quarter of the northeast
quarter of the southeast quarter of the
southwest quarter of section 28 township
22 south range 61 east
mdb and m being further described as
government lot
104
excellent work trustee guzman thank you
for that
at this time are there any
oral bids
can i say that going once going twice
yeah we we get the gavel are we
good to guess so i think we um
the oral pro okay so there is no
um so we have one bid and it it appears
that we vix we will accept that bid
um
so at this point i'm closing the auction
and at this point i'd like to
request can you please say the amount
again trustee guzman sure it's 530 000
okay thank you very much at this time
i'd like to ask for a motion i have it
thank you justin guzman
um motion for item 5.02 open opening of
sealed bids called for oral bids and
resolution of acceptance of bid offer to
sell real property
sit
number zero
four
acres at the southwest corner of rancho
destino road and east fries avenue
thank you very much for that motion i
see trustee
williams in the queue
i will second that motion can you
identify the price and the bidder if
that's the second motion
i had to motion for us to actually open
the bid
okay
okay thank you council
okay at this time we have a motion by
trustee guzman and a motion by christy
williams
excuse me a second by trustee williams
uh this time
trustees please cast your vote
josie brooks
hi
that motions passes six to zero
thank you so much trustees
okay at this point
now i can do the motion to accept the
highest bid
thank you trustee guzman yes go ahead
okay
i motioned to accept the highest bid in
the amount of 530 000
made by saint charbon maronite catholic
mission las vegas real estate trust for
the purchase of the 2.50
acre parcel located at the southeast
corner of rancho destino and east fries
avenue
thank you trustee guzman i see trustee
williams is in the queue
i will second
thank you trustee williams a motion by
trustee guzman a second by trustee
williams trustees please class cast your
vote trustee brooks
hi
okay that motion passes six to zero
noting trust is missing
is not present today
i am missing her um
thank you so much gentlemen for your
time congratulations
no no no fancy no fancy math footwork
congratulations to the
the winning bidder trustee uh guzman
please share congratulatory notes yes
congratulations to saint charbroil
maronite catholic mission las vegas real
estate trust good luck
excellent thank you so much
at this point in time we'd love to move
on to 5.03
public hearing and possible approval of
the new memorandum of agreement between
the clark county school district and the
clark county association of school
administrators and professional
technical employees regarding article
16-9
this is the time in place to conduct a
public hearing on a discussion of and
possible action on approval of the new
memorandum of agreement between the
clark county school district and the
clark county association
of school administrators and
professional technical employees
those who wish to address the board in
person at the meeting may speak
may sign up to speak by calling the
board office
this is all details that are remote
point so this is the time and place to
conduct a public hearing on discussion
of and possible action of approval of
the new memorandum of agreement between
ccsd and the clark county association of
school administrators and professional
technical employees regarding article 16
thank you
madam vice president members of the
board of trustees dr jarrah
my name is david hall
chief negotiator and assistant general
counsel
nevada revised statute 288.153
requires that any new extended or
modified collective bargaining agreement
between a local government employer and
an employee organization be approved by
the governing body of the local
government
excuse me
the local government employer and an
employee organization be approved by the
governing body of the local government
employer at a public hearing and that
the chief executive officer of the local
government shall report to the local
government the fiscal impact of the
agreement
the board of trustees of the clark
county school district or ccsd approved
a negotiated agreement with the clark
county association of school
administrators and professional
technical employees hereafter to be
referred to as kasapi
on october 28
2021
an agreement has been reached pending
approval by the board of trustees and
the superintendent of schools regarding
the new memorandum of agreement between
ccsd and kasapi regarding article 16-9
regarding the executive manager in the
superintendent's office
gusapi and ccsd drafted a new memorandum
of agreement to modify the contract
language in article
16-9 to the current effective day of
july 1st 2019 to december 1st 2021.
the terms of this new agreement will be
effective the date of approval and
signature
any additional costs associated with
entering into this memorandum of
agreement are de minimis
this is the time placed to conduct a
public hearing on discussion of and
possible action on approval of the new
memorandum of agreement between clark
county school district and the clark
county association of school
administrators and professional
technical employees regarding article
16-9
thank you mr hall
i don't we don't see any public comment
on
item 5.03 but this time the public
hearing is now closed
i'm looking for a motion to close the
public hearing
trustee williams
aye motion to close this public hearing
thank you trustee williams
trustee brooks would you like to make a
motion okay i see trustee guzman you're
saved by trustee guzman
i'll second
thank you very much we have a motion by
trustee williams a second by trustee
guzman trustees please class your host
votes
josie brooks
hi
thank you trustees that motion passes
passes six to zero
close the public hearing noting
trustee sepeda is absent
at this point in time we're going to
move on to 5.04 the public hearing and
possible action of approval of the new
memorandum of agreement between the
clark county school district and the
clark county association of school
administrators and professional
technical employees regarding the
11-month
school
regarding 11-month school principles
this is the time and place to conduct a
public hearing on discussion of and
possible action of the approval
the new memorandum of between clark
county school district and the clark
county association school administrators
and professional technical employees
regarding 11-month school principals
we
mr hall thank you madam vice president
members of the board dr jarrah my name
is david hall for the record chief
negotiator and assistant general counsel
nevada revised statute 288.153
requires that any new extended or
modified collective bargaining agreement
between a local government employer and
an employee organization be approved by
the governing body of the local
government employer at a public hearing
and that the chief executive officer or
the local government for the local
government shall report to the local
government the fiscal impact of the
agreement
the board of trustees of the clark
county school district here in after
ccsd
approved in the negotiated agreement
with the clark county association of
school administrators and professional
technical employees here after kassapi
on october 28 2021
an agreement has been reached pending
approval by the board of trustees and
the superintendent of schools regarding
the new memorandum of agreement between
ccsd and kasapi regarding 11-month
school principles
gusapi and ccsd drafted a new memorandum
of agreement to modify the contract
language in article 16-1
to change all current 11-month contracts
for school principals to 12-month
contracts with an effective date
of july 1st 2022
the terms of this new agreement will be
effective the date of approval and
signature the fiscal impact of the
memorandum of agreement is approximately
4.1 million dollars
this is the time and place to conduct a
public hearing on discussion of
impossible action on approval of the new
memorandum of agreement
between the clark county school district
and the clark county association of
school administrators and professional
technical employees regarding 11-month
school principles
trustees before we take any action on
this motion can you guys go can you guys
go back and take a motion to accept the
moa on the previous one all you guys did
was
close the public hearing so that moa is
just sitting in limbo right now we don't
want that
thank you council
excellent just um
excuse me dr darya i saw that you were
in the queue is that the same yep okey
dokey pokey here we go let's uh trusty
williams i see that you are ready to
make a motion
i'll fix it thank you madam president at
this time i'd like to make a motion to
approve
5.03
the
agreement between the clark county
school district and the clark county
association of school administrators
excellent thank you very much we have a
trusty goosebump
oh oh second again
thank you so much we have a motion by
trustee williams a second by trustee
guzman trustees please cast your votes
and trustee brooks
bye
thank you trustees that motion passes
six to zero
uh to approve
the moa
uh item 5.03 thank you very much okay
now we will return back to 5.04
thank you mr hall
i believe we have to
dr jarrow uh thank you thank you let's
see where are we dr jara here we go
matter of vice president members of the
board i just stopped i i can
[Music]
just wanted to make a comment on on the
public hearing if you will on 5.04 i
really like to i know that the executive
director for kasapi is here mr horn
up and really coming to an agreement on
this
move forward as a district
our principals in all our schools
the job has become a 12-month job
and with our staffing and in the efforts
to staff our schools get ready not close
out all the summer work
um this is a long time coming in at the
right move
for our building leaders moving forward
so just really
appreciate the collaboration and moving
forward for our students in our schools
and staff as well thank you
thank you dr jaram
for sharing those sentiments
i don't see any public comment on
a 5.04 so at this time we must close um
no we don't have to
oh
oh okay well let's just close it call it
a day
and move on to
um
emotion the motion part emotion
commotion
is there are there any questions from
trustees i see there's a couple trustees
in the queue who are ready just to nope
no
okay that's we're ready let's do it
trust equals fun thank you i'd like to
make a motion to um accept the
memorandum of agreement to make our um
principles from 11 month to 12 months is
that correct
excellent i see trustee williams is
ready to make a motion too
can i make a friendly amendment to
approve approve not accept does it
accept because the thing says approval
and i don't want to get yelled at by our
attorney again
sounds like it is okay to go approve
approve approve excellent trustees we
have a motion by trustee williams and a
second excuse me a motion but trustee
was monitored second by trustee williams
please cast your vote trustee brooks
hi
thank you trustee brooks that motion
passes six to zero noting
president zepeda is not present today
thank you mr hall for your time
and thank you trustees i'd like to thank
our administrators um thank you who work
diligently to support
our students and families thank you
for your service to our district
at this time we'd like to move on to
at this time we will move on to 6.01
public comment on non-agenda items
we are going to refer to
our sheet here who individuals who have
registered beforehand we have jessica
allen
jessica still here with us
all right we are ready to move on to
yellow cards
mellow yellow let's see we have miss
excuse me sarah esser
sarah present
does it look like sarah
shashanti marshall
anna binder
camilla bywaters
winner winner winner come on down
i'd like to remind uh the audience if
there are additional individuals who
would like to come up for publum agenda
items please complete a yellow card and
we will call you right up
welcome back miss bywaters oh okay
no forgive me welcome back thank you
thank you for coming back i thought you
said i'll come back i was like
you are you are good to go okay camila
bywater is president of the las vegas
alliance of black school educators allow
me to correct the record um i can name
drop mccord mccurdy horseford
i was referring to pressure by ccsd to
pay
large sums of money in a short amount of
time but i am going to move on to a
second correction we've been told by
our leaders
that um
our hr report in regards to black
african american leadership has
increased by 30
and that's actually not accurate i
researched and found the new hr report
and we moved from a whopping 140 black
african american administrative staff
leaders to a whopping 148
over about a five-year span so it seems
like we still have some work to do i do
want to say congratulations and thank
you for the urban the pathway to urban
leadership however one concern that i
would have is that
um that there's a specific target to
increase our black leadership in that
space um i think just kind of leaving it
open um there can be some
um
missed opportunities to really work on
that equity issue there and another
point that i would like to bring up
about the pathway to leadership the
urban leadership plan
how does that incorporate individuals
who are already
have already gone through the
endorsement process and are already
prepared to be principals in schools so
it really just addresses new individuals
who have not had a chance to get a
master's in leadership so i want to just
ensure that
appreciate the work but that we really
make sure that we're
not leaving out people who've still been
in a pipeline and have not had
opportunity to
um
be promoted
thank you are there any other
individuals who'd like to provide public
health i do not have cards at this time
i'm looking for a motion from
my colleagues and i am out of time
let's see it's okay thank you
thank you trustee guzman i appreciate
your support during today's meeting
trustee williams thank you madam vice
president this time i'd like to make a
motion to adjourn this meeting
thank you trustee williams
trustee guzman
i second
trustees please cast your vote trustee
brooks
bye
that motion passes six to zero
noticing oh do you guys need to announce
when the next meeting was
wow
before we accept that oh thank you i
wasn't following my notes here and i'm
so grateful for the check
all right ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen
upcoming meetings board of trustees is
monday may 16th
that is a budget meeting it's at 5 30
p.m it's a special meeting 5 30 p.m the
next meeting of the board of trustees is
on
may 19th on thursday may 19th at five
o'clock
all right at this time we will accept
the motion that um
our trustee colleagues mate six to zero
noting trustees
is
dearly missed grateful thank you for
your time everybody wishing you a good
evening
do
[Music]
[Music]
you